hello everyone welcome to the march 2021
ask me anything episode of the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and as most of you know this is
something that is made
possible by donations from patrons on
patreon
so once a month we do an episode where
patrons get to ask questions and then i
will try to answer them
and then a couple weeks later we'll get
the transcript made and release the
results into the wild and to the public
so thanks to the patrons
for supporting this and the number of
patrons
the number of questions has been growing
so we finally reached a point where
rather than just trying to answer every
question i will pick
some subset of the questions to answer
those and so
therefore this is the first time we've
been doing it and we'll see how it goes
let me know please do
uh feel free to chime in your opinions
as to how it's going
how do i choose which questions to
answer you might ask
so it turns out that well you know i'm
still trying to answer a lot of
questions i don't want to just pick five
questions out of 100 or 200 and and
answer those i want to give as many
people a chance to ask something as
possible
but it's a weird unpredictable set of
criteria that i
that i use actually and maybe not even
completely explicable or articulatable
some questions for example were
perfectly good questions most questions
are really good in some contexts but i
just don't have anything
interesting to say about them so i
skipped those
and some of those were sort of fun
questions like what's your favorite
dessert well
i don't have a very fun favorite dessert
i don't know ice cream
apple pie something like that uh so it
just didn't seem to be the kind of thing
to you know
um give myself time to
it on when i have nothing to say so
often times if i don't pick your
question it's more a comment on me
than a comment on your question okay um
and other questions are just
also interesting but uh in in some realm
that i either don't have anything to say
about or i've said too much about
already and i
i am interested in saying other things
um so but i think
i think it'll work out pretty well uh
anyway you'll let me know right
we still have plenty of questions to get
through so let's go
[Music]
so before we officially start let me
have some words on
time dilation and special relativity and
those kinds of questions because i
actually called them out
uh in the little call for questions i
mentioned that these are not my favorite
kinds of questions and yet some were
asked uh fewer than usual
but so let me let me rather than answer
them explain why these are not my
favorite questions because it's not like
they're
again bad questions are perfectly good
questions and it's certainly
these questions are asked by people who
are trying better to understand
difficult physics right so that's the
kind of thing that i want to encourage
but it's it's a specific genre of
question
that i just get tired of answering
myself because there is some kind of
phase transition your brain goes
through when you learn relativity uh
from the point where
these questions about time dilation and
and either in special relativity or in
general relativity when you have black
holes or whatever
they go from being just completely
ineffably mysterious to like completely
obviously let you get it right you
you like it suddenly clicks and you
understand it and
once you've reached that point then sort
of articulating it over and over again
you just find yourself repeating
yourself and it's less interesting
um so let me try to sort of give my once
and for all
answer to how one should think about
this
kind of thing you know i noticed it
again on twitter recently when we just
recently had the lander
the perseverance lander landing on mars
and someone
you know we know that mars is seven
light minutes away
roughly speaking so uh depends on the
place it is in the orbit and so forth
but
there's a delay from the signal getting
from there to us
and there's a perfect opportunity to
talk about special relativity which i
didn't really do but i just you know
made a joke about the fact that someone
said
we you know we had we know that uh the
landing has either happened or it had
not happened but we don't yet know
whether it's been successful and i said
on twitter you know
actually i was that guy i said
well in some reference frame it's
happened or not happened in another
reference frame it hasn't happened yet
right because mars is sufficiently far
away that you cannot
blindly extend your local reference
frame in a unique way
people moving at different speeds will
get different answers to uh what's going
on
and which is you know not the world's
best observation or anything like that
but people objected to it right
people were like no no there is a fact
of the matter about whether
it's landed or not you just don't know
and i think that represents
just a misunderstanding of special
relativity i did i made a follow-up joke
which was better about the fact that
ah the landing is now in our past light
cone because being in our past light
cone
is in fact a real physical thing
happening at the same time is not a real
physical thing
that's exactly what special relativity
is about you cannot define
simultaneity for events that are very
very
far away in space so what's going on
there what is the whole
issue that is that is uh such a
difficulty
and i think it comes back to the fact
that our intuition
our view of the world that we grow up
with is very
much steeped in the newtonian limit if
you want to think about it that way
of special relativity right newtonian
mechanics can be thought of as a
limiting case of special relativity
that is perfectly valid as long as all
of the objects that you're talking about
are moving much more slowly than the
speed of light
which you and i are we are moving
through our lives even if we're in a
very fast
jet airplane much slower than the speed
of light okay
so as a result there are two different
things two different notions of the word
time that are separate in special
relativity but are the same
in newtonian mechanics so let's let's
see where that comes from
you know there's a notion of time that
is our measured
time on our clocks okay the time that
clocks
measure so you and i we can have watches
and we can measure time and if we move
through the universe we can both equally
measure time right
and as long as we're moving slowly with
respect to the speed of light
with respect to each other then the
following thing happens
you and i can get together and we can
synchronize our watches
right assuming we're wearing accurate
time keeping devices
we can synchronize our watches so we
know they measure the same time
and then we go off and we do our things
you know we execute our bank heist or
whatever it is
then we meet up afterward and we look at
our watches and if they read the same
when we started and they're accurate
time pieces they still measure
the same so that's going to be true for
any number of people in the universe as
long again as you're in this newtonian
limit you're moving slowly compared to
the speed of light
so what this makes you do what it makes
isaac newton do and all of us and our
intuitions
is to associate the passage of time
not with individual people or time
keeping devices
but with the universe right with
something objective and real
and out there you think that we're just
measuring the
passage of time right that's what our
watches apparently are doing
so special relativity comes along and
says no
that is not what we're doing the
objective real
physical thing is the time measured by
observers along
their path but that time is not
universal it is not objective
it is as i've often said it is exactly
like distance in space
you can have a path between two points
in space
and you have a straight line path or you
can have a curvy path
no one in their right minds ever thinks
that all paths between two points in
space
must be of the same distance right the
straight line path is the shortest
distance one
there are also curved distance paths
that will be longer
distances so special relativity says
that the time between two events
as measured by observers carrying their
watches is
like that it's like distance it will be
different
for different observers you don't notice
it usually because you all move slowly
compared to the speed of light
but if you did start moving fast
compared to the speed of light
not fast compared to the speed of light
but at or near the speed of light right
and you left the same event in space
time where you synchronized your clocks
and you go off in two different paths
and you come back and you meet again
at some other event the time that passes
on your watch and the time that passes
on someone else's watch will be
different
okay because it's just like taking two
different paths through
space you're measuring two different
things the space time
interval the temporal interval or what
physicists call the proper time
on two very different trajectories why
should they be the same even if they
begin at the same event and
end at the same event if they're
different trajectories they will have
different
proper times okay so what this
means is that it it separates
the notion of the time that you feel and
you experience the proper time and
that's an objective real measurable
thing
from an entirely different idea which is
the coordinate that we put on space-time
to locate things
okay so we might put coordinates on the
universe or even just on our local
solar system or something like that that
tell us where and when things are
a full four-dimensional coordinate
system okay
and we all know that coordinate systems
are not
physical real objective things they are
inventions of the human mind
one person can use one coordinate system
another person can use another
coordinate system
so special relativity says that if you
want to talk about
the time it is right now here on earth
and try to extend that to a notion of
time on mars
you can do that by choosing a coordinate
system
right typically what we do implicitly is
we imagine that we
are moving slowly compared to the speed
of light and we you know imagine
send out a whole army of little clocks
that fill space
that start their lives um in our rest
frame and move very very
slowly to get to their locations and so
we extend our rest frame
uh throughout the universe but that's
highly non-unique if someone else has
been moving at a different speed or if
you just
picked some weird curvilinear coordinate
system that would also be just as good
okay so the very notion
of when the
thing on mars landed when perseverance
landed
from our point of view that's just not a
well-defined
notion in special relativity what you
can say is
it's in our past if it's in our past
light cone if a signal from that event
could get to us by moving at or more
slowly than the speed of light then it's
in our past
if it's not then all you can say is it's
not
technically the term would be it's
space-like separated from us but there's
no
deep reality to the idea of did it
happen already yet or not that notion of
simultaneity is just not well defined
it's like saying you know it's really
exactly like saying okay here i am
sitting in los angeles
where would i be if i were in new york
city i mean that just makes no sense
there's no unique way of extending my
location throughout space right i could
put some coordinates i could put x y
coordinates
latitude longitude coordinates et cetera
and i could say
am i at the same latitude or whatever
but that's a completely arbitrary
choice so all of the questions and
special relativity about
time dilation length contraction all of
these things
they're all instantly dissolved in your
head if you really believe
that how time should be measured is
along individual trajectories
there's the extra little um confusion
that for space the shortest distance
between two points is a straight line
for time the longest time between two
events is a straight line so if you
zoom out of the speed of light or you
hang out near a black hole
you will always have experienced less
time when you re-convene
to compare your clocks but otherwise the
math works out very very similarly
so i just never like it when people talk
about well time is flowing more slowly
near a black hole or time moves more
slowly when you move near the speed of
light
that's nonsense time moves at one second
per second
when you're far away in relativity you
just shouldn't compare
the rate at which time flows you should
only talk about that
the rate at which time is measured by
individuals and that rate is
always one second per second you can
globally come back
to where you uh left and meet up with
the people that you left behind and then
compare the total amount of elapsed
time but that's not a rate of anything
flowing okay
and my belief is that once you truly
internalize this way of thinking about
time dilation and special relativity you
get it and you're
you're free to ask questions on podcast
amas that have nothing to do
with time dilation anymore and it's a
wonderful moment in your life worth
celebrating and remembering for the rest
of the of the time
all right that's not a specific answer
to any particular question but those are
my thoughts on time dilation so i hope
that those are useful now i can point
here
uh whenever anyone is tempted to ask
such questions so moving on to the
actual questions and i
sort of scrambled the order a little bit
but of course uh
i will publish when i publish the
transcripts i'll publish uh the list of
questions that were asked
so duncan palmer says i'm grateful you
shared your
you shared the podcast of your personal
oral history and it's an oral history of
my personal history
and you are making a professional life
change right now if resources and money
were not constraints how would you
devote your time and energy differently
post covid
than you are currently planning to do so
the reason
i promoted this question um to the very
first
slot here is because i wanted to say
something that i should have said
before to especially to those patrons
out there who are supporting the podcast
i for those of you who don't know the
context here uh i mentioned on twitter
and also on this aip oral history
interview
that i did that i'll be leaving caltech
uh
next summer uh so a year and or year and
a
half
from now something like that and you
know they it's it's my choice they i
have a
contract that is renewed every five
years and i'm choosing not to renew it
and so
why am i doing that um well it's a
complicated
set of many different issues going into
it but you know basically what it comes
down to is that
it's uh i am no longer a very good fit
for caltech and caltech is not a very
good fit for me
and vice versa okay and this actually
has you know uh there's a lot we could
say about this and it's nothing against
caltech
caltech
is a tremendously wonderful place for
the right person
for the right situation it's just not my
situation right now
um my own research interests have
drifted as as i hope that people's
research interests do you don't want to
keep continue to do the same thing you
did in graduate school for the rest of
your career although there are people
who do that and yeah look if
if it works for you that's great that's
not my thing i should say that's not the
way that i like to be
and in particular you know this goes
back to a feature of modern fundamental
physics which is that it's a bit
stuck right now as i've mentioned in
other places in other contexts
talked a little bit about this with
frank wilczak i've talked a little bit
about this
in the biggest ideas videos in the very
last video
uh about science itself you know we have
these incredibly successful
models of the universe the standard
model of particle physics general
relativity
uh the standard cosmological model etc
and
all the experiments we do roughly
speaking fit these models
okay so we know these models are not the
final answer we need to do better we
haven't quantized gravity we don't
understand the black hole information
problem or what the dark matter is or
what happened at the big bang is a
million questions we don't understand
but our guidance to finding better
answers
is not coming from experimental
surprises as it usually does
in physics so we're reduced to a
situation where in order to get
better answers we kind of have to guess
right and so you guess
how to extend beyond the standard model
there's a whole you know subfield of
physics called beyond the standard model
and that's particle physics in
particular
and there's a whole other set of areas
about quantizing gravity unifying things
et cetera et cetera
these are all guesses the right model of
inflation the right model of dark matter
you guess you hypothesize
and there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that that is the right
thing to do this is how science makes
progress you make a guess
hypothesis test it against the data etc
but i personally uh and i played that
game for a long time but i personally
uh have become convinced that i'm just
not going to guess the right answer
by this method uh you know when i was uh
at the university of chicago i wrote a
paper with some of my collaborators
uh on modifying gravity to explain the
acceleration of the universe right
uh something that is now called f of r
gravity a function of r
f of r r being the curvature scalar of
space time
this is a way of modifying gravity very
simple very very straightforward kind of
obvious way of modifying gravity makes
the universe accelerate
the paper was um uh helped inspire a lot
of
other people to do a lot of other work
uh
lots of uh industry of sort of figuring
out what are the cosmological
implications of this what are the
predictions etc okay
so i could have just become the world's
expert on f of r gravity or modified
gravity and its cosmological
implications right and that would have
been a very
standard respectable cosmological
career to have i would have gotten
tenure somewhere
no worries you know gotten citations the
whole bit
but you know i think that there's it's
just not very likely
that f r gravity is the correct theory
that describes the universe number one
uh it's possible so it's very worth
doing and thinking about but i wouldn't
say it's probable
and uh you know furthermore i'm just not
constructed to you know come up with an
idea and then devote 20 years to
investigating it
that's just not how i work and again
nothing wrong with people who do work
that way but once
i sort of figure out the idea i want to
move on to figure out other ideas
and it's just become harder and harder
to figure out interesting ideas along
those lines
which has caused me to shift my research
direction like when i
go to talks uh in the seminar series or
the colloquial or whatever that are
about someone's model for dark matter or
dark energy or inflation or whatever
i just find it you know not that
compelling because what are the chances
that this is the real world which is
ultimately what i care about
um and as i say in the biggest ideas
video
under those kinds of circumstances
there's different things you can do
and one of the things you can do which
is what i have chosen to do
is sort of take a step backward and look
at the
underlying foundations of the field
you're thinking about so whether it's
the sort of philosophy of quantum
mechanics or cosmology or statistical
mechanics
or general questions about emergence and
complexity and things like that
that's what i have decided uh is a much
better place for me to spend
my efforts um so like i said when i go
to
particle physics seminars i just it's
just not interesting to me personally
these days in the way that it used to be
whereas when i go to foundations of
physics talks
uh you know they we have a uh i go to
several
zoom series let's put it that way about
philosophy physics and foundations of
physics
or when i spend time at santa fe and
talk to people about complexity and
things like that
i have this you know enormous
intellectual excitement right and that's
what i want to have that's what you
should have
as a working scientist so i've shifted
my
research interests and it's no longer a
good fit
caltech hired me to do this particular
kind of research
and i'm not interested in doing that
research anymore i'm interested in doing
other things
and furthermore like my other than just
writing papers
my single most important job at caltech
was advising graduate students right
helping people get their phds
working with them collaborating with
them launching them on their careers you
know something that i
care a lot about take a lot of pride in
and so forth um but it got to the point
where
and i've had amazingly good graduate
students at caltech and zero complaints
about that they've been fantastic
but i got to the point where i thought
that i was letting them down and they
were slowing me down uh
through neither my fault or their fault
but
there's a system that we're all embedded
in right i mean the people
who were my graduate students entered
physics
graduates to school at caltech to get a
phd and become theoretical physicist
doing particle physics gravity cosmology
that kind of thing and i had lost
interest
in doing those things to some extent the
kinds of things the kind of research
that i wanted to do
would not get these students jobs
right it would not launch them on a
successful scientific career
my my current interests are too
idiosyncratic and weird to do that and
it wasn't what they wanted to do anyway
that's not why they
came to grad school at cal tech because
they were attracted by cosmology and
particle physics and field theory
um so i needed to sort of you know
change what i
wanted to do to help them out and yet i
wasn't very good at doing that right
like you can't really fake
that kind of enthusiasm so i don't think
that i gave them
the projects to work on that would
absolutely maximize
their chances of becoming successful
physicists
so i thought that you know uh i wasn't a
good fit either way
so anyway long version of saying that
i've decided that being a caltech wasn't
a good fit for me and
now we're coming to the punch line here
um
so i don't need to be a caltech anymore
and it
some large factor in not me making me
need to be at caltech
is you folks the patrons that are
helping out the mindscape podcast
i can pay my salary through a
combination
of the podcast writing books giving
talks things like that
so i don't need to be at caltech anymore
it was a good thing to be there when i
got intellectual
use out of it but now i'm not doing that
either right
so now i can do exactly the work i want
to do
because no one can tell me i don't need
to worry about you know
what the grant people think what my
bosses think or anything like that
i can do exactly the stuff i want to do
and i spend you know
a day a week doing the podcast and a day
or two a week writing books or whatever
or giving talks and the rest of the time
i can do my
work they do my research and it's a
weird thing because you know
exactly in the the um it's in the nature
of
podcasts and books and talks that those
things
get a much bigger audience than the work
i do writing papers and things like that
but you know
the papers that i want to write um are
the most important thing to me
and they do feed into of course the
podcast and the books and so forth so
it's not they're not completely
independent
so now i can do things like you know
this fall uh i've been invited to spend
a sabbatical at harvard
talk to people there santa fe institute
reached out and they want me to
come spend more time there and talking
to those folks
and i can do all this because i'm 100
free
from any obligation to any other place
now i say this with a complete um
knowledge that
it might very well be that if i come
back to a year from now i might say you
know look i got a job offer that was
really good and i took it
so if i get if i if there were an
academic job
that let me do the work i wanted to do
in the way i want to do it then that
would be even better
than being a freelancer because then i
would be it's all about you know the
thing that you're missing by not having
that position
is colleagues to talk to right so that's
one of the reasons why i'm
going to go around visiting places spend
more time at
sfi and things like that uh hire post
docs and
do grant proposals at sfi so that i can
keep
you know talking to people who have the
same interests as me but i didn't want
to like send out a word of thanks to all
of the
people uh um supporting on patreon
because you're a big help in in this
project and so it's not just the podcast
that you're making possible
by doing this not just the amas so
duncan to the answer to your question
what would i do differently nothing what
i'm doing now
for you know maybe the first time in my
life is nothing more or less than
exactly what i want to do
and hopefully i can keep doing that all
right
simo vaisanan says what was your journey
into theoretical physics and how have
how come you decided to become a
physicist and not a mathematician
um yeah i i sometimes get asked this and
i don't think i ever give especially
helpful
answers because i was young and i just
stumbled into it you know it wasn't some
choice and i loved it and decided to do
that and here i am doing it
um the difference between physicist and
mathematician again i was never tempted
to be a mathematician
at all uh math i love
math i love certain things that one
learns by studying mathematics
but doing math as a career was just
never
something i took as a serious
possibility because i care about the
real world that
ultimately what's driving me is how does
the world work
and mathematics uh sometimes applies to
the real world sometimes doesn't
the you know the whole personality
difference between physicists and
mathematicians is that mathematicians
uh are not content to stop when they're
pretty sure something is right they need
to prove it
right that's not my personality if i
think that something is pretty much
right i want to move on to do
something else so you know on twitter
some friends of mine are discussing the
question
uh someone raised on twitter the
question what do we know about the
number
pi to the power of pi to the power of pi
to the power of pi so this is very
more complicated than it sounds like you
can't just plug it into your uh
uh pocket calculator because the
uncertainties when you raise
one number to another power and then you
do real number arithmetic rather than
arbitrary arithmetic
um or you know finite power arithmetic i
should say
uh the uncertainties build up very very
quickly and so there's an interesting
math question about how well you can
approximate such a number
and i just have zero interest in this
like this little puzzle solving like
i'm just completely not into these weird
math puzzles
that people like to set for themselves
if it's not the world
if it's not a step to describing the
actual world it's not for me again
let a thousand flowers bloom i'm very
very happy that there are people out
there
who do care about these things but that
those people are not me so that was
never a decision i was really faced with
okay we have three questions in a row
that are on similar i've sort of tried
to group some similar questions together
so
here's the first group mystery horse
says do you practice any kind of art or
do you know
of any other theoretical scientists who
do tim ryan says if you could choose to
excel at any art form what would you
choose
and rocket rat says do you have any
hidden talents like juggling making good
wookie sounds blowing bubble gum bubbles
etc
um well you know so the
short the to get to what people actually
want to know
um i'm not good at any other art form no
i have no talents uh but you know i wish
i live in a world and this is true for
art as well as for science i wish i
lived in a world where
uh we didn't try to confine
the practice of art to experts
um you know science is a different thing
because the practice of science requires
a certain amount of expertise
but in art that you know that's the
difference between doing it and doing it
well
right like i don't think that people
like me should be up there on stage
singing you don't want to hear me
singing on stage trust me about that
um but i think that people should you
know
play instruments more and they should
paint more especially when we have all
these technologies
um to enable us to do it you know i
think that the podcast did quite a while
ago with grimes
uh was inspirational in this area you
know she took a course in a neuroscience
class and they were told to you know do
something about music and she
made an album and decided realized that
she could do it with the technology that
was available and that doesn't mean it's
easy that doesn't mean we can all be as
good
uh but we should be able to democratize
art a lot more
so as i think i have said before one of
my quarantine
projects was uh learning bass guitar
something i've always wanted to learn to
do and look there's no question i have
no talent for this
at all i cannot keep time i do not have
a good ear
none of the things that would be good
i'm too old to really you know learn
something from scratch
but it's fun i like it i do it and you
know i enjoy doing it so
that is my attitude towards art forms as
scientists
and i should say some other scientists
are great at uh
at either art or music or whatever
i do also i did go through a phase where
i painted acrylics abstracts
and again they were not very good but it
was fun to do and i think that should be
an attitude that more people have
okay jim cecilian says does the motion
of the earth around the sun
the sun around the milky way the milky
way itself affect the cosmic microwave
background
does this make the cmb a preferred
reference frame for the universe
so yes it absolutely does um the cmb
does have a rest frame as a sort of gas
of particles
there is a frame in which the radiation
coming from you is on average completely
isotropic
same temperature in all directions if
you move with respect to that rest frame
then in one direction the photons get
blue shifted in the opposite direction
they get redshifted
and this gives a dipole pattern of
temperature variations on the
cmb sky so it looks hotter in one
direction cooler in another direction
and we absolutely observed that that was
the first anisotropy of the cb that was
observed a long time ago
but we know it's not intrinsic to the
early universe it's something that is
just due to our local motion with
respect to the cmb
so yes cosmologists know about this they
take into account they remove it from
the maps that they show you
usually although you can find pictures
of the
cosmic microwave background dipole
online if you want just google those
words
uh does it make the scene be a preferred
reference frame you know it's a
reference frame
but whether or not it's preferred is a
trickier question what do you mean by
preferred you know
um the we always leave out some details
when we try to translate the ideas of
relativity and
anything else into ordinary english but
there's absolutely nothing wrong
with having a preferred rest frame and
special relativity right
here in my office i have a preferred
rest frame at rest with respect to
tables and chairs that are around me
that does not violate the rules of
relativity or physics
what the real rules are is that there's
no rest frame in the vacuum
there's no rest frame that is intrinsic
to the laws of physics themselves
when you have stuff whether it's a
planet or the microwave background or
whatever
then of course you can measure your
speed with respect to that stuff and
call that a rest frame with when you're
at rest with respect to that stuff
and the cmb lets you do that james
kiddick says
when the super lotto got huge i used the
universe splitter app to generate enough
bits of randomly chosen numbers
and bought one ticket to each lottery uh
the me posting this comment didn't win
but do you believe
one of me did um
it's not that one of you did someone did
i do believe that someone did but
they're no longer you
right this is this is the lesson of the
sea of the
many worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics all those other branches have
different
people that descended from the same past
you but now are no longer you
they're different people just like if
you had an identical twin
so uh yep i think that overall the
collection of people who are descended
from you lost money but there should be
one out there who won money unless the
lottery was rigged in which case i can't
help you there
uh okay another few questions that i've
grouped and i've grouped together
groupin uh kirkbriggs says why is
temperature
not symmetrical absolute zero is the
minimum and there's no maximum
could time be similar with a beginning
and a no end uh
michael edelman says at the cost of
building particle accelerators
as the cost of building particle
accelerators continues to grow the cost
of doing some other kinds of science has
decreased
can you imagine that there might exist a
new approach to high energy physics that
could be done
if not on a tabletop at least in a small
laboratory
and anonymous says we think there's
plenty of particle physics we're missing
because we can't get temperatures high
enough
do we have reasons to rule out there
being major particle physics we're
missing because we can't get to
temperatures
low enough so i hope it's
clear why these three are at least
somewhat related maybe i didn't read
them in the best possible order
look there's why is temperature not
symmetrical there's plenty of things
that are not symmetrical right the set
of all positive numbers
is not symmetrical and temperature is
kind of like that
classically temperature is just the
average kinetic energy
in a collection of molecules in thermal
equilibrium so kinetic energy is a
non-negative number right if an object
has zero velocity
it has zero kinetic energy and the
kinetic energy is one half mv squared so
v
squared is a positive number you're
never going to get it to be
below zero so that's fine i mean there's
nothing really to be explained there um
could time be similar
short time can go to minus infinity to
plus infinity or
time might go from zero to plus infinity
or time might go from 0 to some big
number that we don't know about we don't
know anything about
what those possibilities which of those
possibilities are really true
is there something called low
temperature particle physics just like
there's high temperature particle
physics you know
probably not but we don't know for sure
right we never know these things for
sure these are always
our best guesses but according to the
philosophy of effective quantum field
theories
quantum field theories that work at one
energy scale
typically work below that energy scale
it's just part of the
structure of quantum field theory but
they might not work at energies above
that energy scale there really is a
difference between going down
in energy and going up in energy and i
talk about this again in the biggest
pictures
uh biggest ideas in the universe videos
uh we talk about
why that is true in the normalization
video uh ken wilson's ideas about
quantum field theory
so uh probably not but you know
you never know so um i think that what
to get people interested in that one
would have to come up with a particular
model
in which new phenomena arose at low end
at low temperatures low energies
long wavelengths and that's hard to do
maybe gravity has something to do with
it who knows but it's not what you would
typically
expect which by the way is one of the
reasons why
it's probably not true that gravity is
modified on cosmological scales right we
had a very good theory of gravity
general relativity that works in the
solar system etc
it would be really weird for that theory
to break down on galaxy or universe size
scales but we don't know for sure so we
keep looking
as far as particle physics experiments
are concerned you know
just for the reasons i just gave um
the best bet to find new phenomena
experimentally in particle physics is to
do
go to higher energies smash particles
together with more and more
momenta so you can be clever
in particular models like there are
particular models for dark matter where
if you shine light at a wall
sometimes the light will turn into dark
matter and then turn back out so some of
the light will pass through the wall
and you can actually use that to test
ideas about axions and so forth
but those are very highly model
dependent and again any one of them is
unlikely to be
the right answer whereas if you just go
to high energies and smash particles
together
eventually you're guaranteed almost to
find something new
so you can try to be more clever
about doing particle physics at low
energies but it's just not
as guaranteed to pay off as it is
by going to higher energies and
furthermore there are plenty of
interesting phenomena
that we can imagine that can only be
found by going to high energy
it's not that we're just not thinking
hard enough that's where they are and
you got to go there
to see them so there is a sub version of
your question which is
can we go to high energy can we smash
particles together with enormous
energies
without building giant particle
accelerators that are kilometers across
and billions of dollars to build
you know we would all love to be able to
do that and there are people who are
thinking about doing it there's a whole
industry of what is called plasma
wakefield accelerators etc
so far they don't work so far it's not
been very promising
but you know that would change
everything if you could really do that
if you could build the equivalent of the
large hadron collider in your basement
like tony stark somehow is able to do
then uh it would change the
economics of high-energy particle
physics enormously no one wants these
experiments to cost 10 billion dollars
right
we all want to be able to do them at our
own universities
but we need a huge breakthrough in
technology to make that happen and
i i'm not in a position to tell you
whether or not that's a likely
breakthrough or not eric klein
says if the mythical machines for going
back in time exist and you travel back
in time six months would you appear
in the point in space where you were in
space currently but the earth is where
it was six months ago
causing you to be floating in space on
the other side of the sun um
well there's a reason why these machines
are mythical
right uh typically you know
the movie version of time travel
is wrong in a million different ways and
and you're pointing out one of the ways
in which it's wrong it
it takes you to this typically the same
location in earth right like if you
travel back in time in your basement
you end up in the future or the past in
your basement
uh but we know that in fact what you're
doing is you're traveling to a different
location
in space time why in the world should
you still be in your basement
so it depends on what your mythical time
machine is
the most real world version would be a
wormhole
that literally connected two different
regions of spacetime so
then the answer is you climb in your
wormhole and you go to wherever the
wormhole comes out
and you should be able to predict that
ahead of time i hope so it's not like
you're completely lost
but there's no reason why it has to be
the same point in space with respect to
the earth
that it was when you left james kirkland
says i've long been fascinated by
electroweak false vacuum decay i wonder
if anyone has done the work to find out
what the new stable symmetry breaking
would look like
uh yeah no absolutely so this idea is
we know from in the standard model of
particle physics that there is a
symmetry group
su 2 cross u1 that is broken by the
higgs field
down to just a u1 amount of symmetry and
if all those letters and
numbers don't mean anything that's fine
what it means is that
there's a certain amount of symmetry in
what we call the electro weak theory
and the higgs field gets a non-zero
value in empty space
which breaks that symmetry and it's very
much like you know imagine you have
a sphere in space and you can rotate it
right you can rotate it in all different
directions
sort of three different directions
there's three different axes around
which you can rotate it
but then you put a dot on the sphere and
you say i'm gonna
now well what you say is what is the
symmetry group now that i have a dot on
the sphere
if i move the sphere that in a way that
moves the dot
that's not a symmetry anymore right a
symmetry is a transformation that keeps
something
unaffected but there is still some
symmetry you can move
around the axis defined by the dot right
you can rotate
the sphere in such a way so the dot
doesn't move
so there's a little bit of unbroken
symmetry in that case and that's
very analogous to what happens in the
standard model of particle physics the
higgs
boson picks out a direction in field
space
and some of it remains invariant and
that gives rise to electromagnetism
as we know it the rest remains broken
and that gives rise to the weak
interactions as we know them
and so it has been hypothesized that
this higgs field in empty space
might be not completely stable that the
higgs field could
suddenly jump to a much bigger value at
some point in time that would be
electroweak false vacuum decay
and the question is would the symmetry
breaking change and the i
the answer in the models that i know
about is no so
the amount of symmetry breaking would
change but
which symmetry was broken would not
change there would still be
electromagnetism there'd still be the w
and z bosons
so it would still be sc2 cross u1 breaks
down to
just u1 you need a completely different
field that
is also charged under electromagnetism
to get a non-zero expectation value in
empty space to also break
that u1 so that would be a different
kind of thing
peter benham says i was rewatching your
big ideas videos on fields
and was struck by how the infinite
number of modes results in an infinite
amount of energy and how that sounds a
lot like the same problem we had with
the ultraviolet
catastrophe um so yes and no i think
like
just because two things are infinite
doesn't mean they're equal right you
have to be a little bit
careful um so there's there's quantum
field theory and there's quantum gravity
okay and these are slightly different
things
in quantum field theory there's sort of
things are infinite in at least three
different ways
uh in quantum field theory you can think
of what's going on there's a field
pervading all of space
and it's very very convenient to analyze
what's happening to that field
in terms of modes as we call them which
are just
sine waves right like plane waves
stretching throughout all of space
with a fixed wavelength vibrating with
some amplitude okay
and so if you think in terms of those
way just pick a certain mode and there's
three different ways that sort of things
can go wrong
not not wrong but you know you might get
an infinite answer
one way is if the wavelength of the
modes you're thinking about
is taken to be infinitely long right
the energy in a mode goes down
when the wavelength goes up especially
if the field is massless like the photon
or the graviton or whatever
so there are what are called infrared
divergences because
very very long wavelength modes of
electromagnetism for example
are easy to make they cost no energy and
that's sort of a calculational problem
when people learn to deal with that
there's another infinity that you could
get when the modes become very very
short wavelength this is an
ultraviolet infinity and ultraviolet
divergence
and that's what happens in particle
physics once you turn on interactions
the interactions naively can give you
infinite answers
also and maybe this is what you're
referring to peter
when you calculate the vacuum energy the
energy in empty space
if you include the zero point energy
right the quantum intrinsic energy in
all of those modes
you also get an infinite answer to that
because of the ultraviolet
contributions okay so that's the second
infinity there's infrared ultraviolet
then there's a third infinity that for
any fixed wavelength
you know don't let the wavelength get
really big or really small just fix the
wavelength
but let the amplitude of the wave become
really really big
then any fixed wavelength mode can have
an infinite amount of energy
in it and that is a difference between
quantum field theory and quantum gravity
in quantum field theory
that's true but it's just true you can
get informative energy you can get as
much energy as you want
in gravity if you try to put a lot of
energy into a small region of space the
whole thing just collapses into a black
hole
and this even before you get onto
anything fancy about holography or
string theory or whatever
this simple fact that you can't fit an
arbitrary amount of energy into a region
of space
indicates that there is a deep
fundamental difference between gravity
and quantum field theory and so you
should not be surprised
that just trying to quantize general
relativity which is a field theory
uh doesn't work very well okay or other
approaches along those lines
gravity is something very special uh and
that doesn't mean that it's it's not
possible to fit it in to the bigger
picture but we're not going to get there
by just building a more clever
quantum field theory in some ways so to
your question you know there are all
these infinities but they're different
infinities okay there's different kinds
of infinity that come up
and you need to just be on your toes
when you refer to
a problem with infinities in these
contexts
sam barta says why do physicists give so
much credence and real-world
significance to determinism
given quantum mechanics quantum
randomness
i think it's a very misleading thing to
a general audience um well i don't know
that physicists do do that i'm not sure
exactly what uh
you're referring to you know some some
physicists well let's let's back up you
know i wrote a whole
blog post a while ago you can look up
about determinism and when it appears
and when it doesn't
um certainly in quantum mechanics uh the
predictions we make
are not deterministic let's put it that
way whether the fundamental underlying
structure is deterministic or not is
less clear
but the empirical predictions we make
for observable things are not
deterministic so yeah so in that sense
physics is not deterministic
on the other hand if you want to play
baseball
or play soccer or get a rocket to mars
you don't need to worry about that
quantum and determinism
the relevant physical rules on the
relevant scales are pretty darn
deterministic
right so it's there is to some extent
just a question
of accuracy right you know there's a an
extent
to which physics is deterministic and
that's fine and there's an extent to
which it's
not um just i mean maybe what you have
in mind is some question about
free will maybe not i really don't know
um
but let me say this free will has
nothing whatsoever at all even a little
bit to do with determinism in fact let's
let's say
even stronger than that when people are
talking about free will
and they start talking about determinism
versus indeterminism you instantly know
not to take them seriously
this is not what the issue is if your
question is whether or not there exists
what we call libertarian free will
the ability to sort of be a law unto
yourself in a monument
formulation the ability to not be
governed by the laws of physics what
matters is not whether the laws of
physics are
deterministic or not what matters is
just that there are
laws the fact that quantum mechanics is
indeterministic has
absolutely zero to do with free will
because it's not your free will making
the choice about whether the spin is
measured up or down right
laws can be random and stochastic or
they can be deterministic the question
is whether or not you obey
the laws if your question is about
libertarian
free will so um i'm not sure why
uh in what context the people you're
thinking of are talking about
determinism but you i would i would
advocate being careful about that
context
jeff b says in the biggest ideas series
you started explaining why we see
discrete particle phenomena despite the
world being composed of wavy fields
is it that the world is wavy but only
interacts in small point-like locations
or is the particle-like behavior a more
elaborate emerging phenomenon from all
the waving
um i don't think it's either one of
those actually you know i did try to
explain this both in the biggest ideas
videos
and in the book something deeply hidden
but you know it is it's a tricky thing
so i'll try again here we go um it's it
the the simple glib answer is it's
exactly like a vibrating string
and the harmonics of a vibrating string
right if you have if you have a string
and you tie it down or a rubber band or
whatever you tie it down on both ends
so there's boundary conditions where the
string cannot move at the two ends
and you pluck it then there's a discrete
set of vibrational
modes that you can get you can get the
fundamental mode and then you can get
all the overtones okay you can get a
wavelength of
uh the whole thing between the two pegs
or
half that or a quarter that or whatever
okay
that phenomenon is discreteness
from continuity right the string if it
weren't tied down
there's nothing discreet about the
string you know wherever it wants
or the rubber band or whatever but it's
because you tie it down and you provide
boundary conditions that in the presence
of those boundary conditions you get a
discrete set of phenomena
that phenomenon is why particles arise
in quantum mechanics and in quantum
field theory so in particular
in um the original word quantum
came to be because we were seeing
discrete packets of energy released by
atoms um so i'm not going to i'm not
going to get the history exactly right
here but
you know that electrons can move to
higher and lower energy levels in atoms
and they emit or absorb photons while
doing it
and only certain photons are emitted or
absorbed certain energies of those
photons
and the reason why is because there's a
discrete set of orbitals
that the electrons can be in if the
electron were not
in the orbit of an atom it could have
any energy at all
but once it falls into the potential
field of the electromagnetic field of
the nucleus of the atom
then it has a boundary condition namely
its wave function is
near the nucleus and goes to zero
far away right and that boundary
condition is enough to say
there's a discrete set of possibilities
exactly with the vibrating violin string
or whatever in quantum field theory it's
a little bit
different but the the concepts are
exactly analogous
so in quantum field theory you do what
we did before uh you can
consider a certain wavelength of a mode
of a quantum field
and that mode you know that wavelength
of the field can vibrate up and down
right
its amplitude goes up and down and you
say well
um i don't see any boundary conditions
there it can vibrate up and down as much
as it wants right
but what you're thinking of and this is
why it's hard to understand but what
you're thinking of is the wave
function of that field okay so wave
functions are not fields wave functions
are assignments
to every configuration of a physical
system a number a complex number the
amplitude
and you would square that amplitude find
out what is the probability of getting
an observational result seeing the
physical
system in that configuration so you say
i have a physical system which is a wave
and it has an amplitude and i have a
wave function which says
what is the probability if i were to
observe
that mode of the field to observe it
with a certain amplitude or a different
amplitude or a different amplitude okay
and there is a boundary condition there
you want
the amplitude the wave function
for observing the field to have
enormously
big amplitude enormously big vibrations
to be zero to go down to zero to fade
away you do not want an arbitrarily
large amount of energy
in your quantum field any finite energy
configuration will have
the feature that the wave function
assigns a very low probability
to the field vibrating too much
that provides boundary conditions that
says that in the in the space of all
possible
uh vibrational amplitudes that the field
can have the wave function
goes to zero as the amplitude gets very
very big
and that once again gives you a discrete
set of possible
vibrational modes and we interpret those
vibrational modes as
there's no particles there there's one
particle there there's two particles
there
etc that's why we get discreteness in
the sense of particles in quantum field
theory because of the boundary
conditions
on the wave function of the quantum
fields
so you know i've been thinking for years
but how to best explain this and that
was it
and it's not very clear i get that but i
do you know having said that
go back to the videos or go back to the
book and see if the description there
makes any more sense that's the general
idea
nate wadoops says what is it that makes
general relativity in quantum mechanics
incompatible i've heard a few times that
they are incompatible i'd love to know
more about why
well i think that there are two whole
big buckets of ideas
that uh go into why general relativity
and quantum mechanics
seem to be incompatible i won't say they
are incompatible
but the straightforward ideas that we
generally have
don't quite work we say there are both
technical
issues and conceptual issues okay
so the technical issues are the
following if you you know
make your life easy just say i'm going
to only think about
very very tiny gravitational fields
right
small perturbations very weak field so
space time is almost flat but i let it
vibrate a little bit
okay and there you can do quantum
gravity perfectly well
that that works pretty well as long as
you don't push it
too hard if you let those small
violations of
small vibrations in the gravitational
field act as
virtual particles so you put them inside
feynman diagrams then the rules
say that you have to in you have to
include
contributions from all possible
wavelengths
of those vibrating gravitational fields
all the way down to
zero and maybe you want to cut it off
with the planck length but
okay that's not what the rules say the
rules say you go down to zero and
you get the infinities that we were
talking about before and this is a fancy
way of saying that quantum gravity is
not renormalizable
okay so what that means is in practice
that there are corrections you basically
start with a classical expectation and
then you quantize it
and what you hope is that the quantum
corrections to your classical
expectations
are small and controllable but in a
non-renormalizable theory they're not
they're big and uncontrollable so you
get infinities everywhere you don't know
what to do and you can
cut them off but you don't know where to
cut them off or how to deal with that or
anything like that so
at the simple technical level of
quantizing gravity and getting a
sensible theory it doesn't work
okay you need to think a little bit more
cleverly about that and obviously people
have
suggested schemes for thinking more
cleverly conceptually
you know gravity is different because
it's a theory of space-time in a way
that other
theories are not all the other theories
you have are theories
on top of space-time okay so if you
think about the schrodinger equation the
schrodinger equation says i have some
quantum state
it evolves with time in a way that is
determined by what we call the
hamiltonian which is a fancy way of
saying the energy
of the quantum state but you use the
rules of
general relativity and you just naively
plug it in
and unlike every other theory general
relativity is about
time and space in a very direct way
and what pops out of the straightforward
follow your nose kind of approach is
that the wave function of the universe
in quantum gravity doesn't
evolve with time at all it's just static
this is what is called the wheeler
dewitt equation after john wheeler and
bryce dewitt
so what do you do about that i mean time
seems to be happening
all around us and it seems that this
most naive version of quantum gravity
says the time doesn't exist uh and this
is literally what is called the problem
of
time in quantum gravity so again people
have solutions to the
problem of time time as emergent or
something like that
and that's great it's not an unsolvable
problem but it is a problem
and so people disagree about what the
right solution
is so those two sets of things both the
technical probability problems that you
just get infinite answers
and the conceptual problems that certain
things that seemed clear and obvious
for other quantum mechanical theories
aren't quite so clear and obvious for
general relativity alexander kavanagh
says have you ever had any phd students
who are violently opposed to the many
world's interpretation
um so short answer no i don't i've never
had any
phd students who are violently opposed
to anything i don't think the phd
students aren't that violent usually
famous exceptions of course but um no
but i get the point uh
so let's let's interpret this as a
broader question um
what happens if uh
an advisor to phd students
has certain ideological commitments and
the students themselves do not share
them
you know usually this just doesn't
happen because
why would you choose as your advisor
someone who you disagreed with
in some very very profound way right
that doesn't really fit together you
generally choose someone as your advisor
uh who you're sympathetic with on the
big questions um
but yeah students have minds of their
owns and opinions of their own so i
don't think i've ever had a phd
student who agreed with me about
anything about everything
anything i said by i was a freudian slip
they agreed with me about many things uh
in fact you know it's it's funny my very
first phd student gave a seminar
uh while he was a graduate student gave
a seminar at a different
university and you know he was answering
some questions
from the audience from the seminar
audience and at some point
he mentioned that he was working with me
and then one of the audience members
goes oh now i understand why you're
saying all these things
so there's some you know you fit into a
tradition that is defined by the work
that is being done
by your advisor um and also by the way
you know most of my research career i
was not thinking about the everett or
many worlds interpretation that much i
was just
doing more or less standard cosmology
general relativity field theory stuff so
the question just didn't arise
okay there's two questions that are
different i'm going to group them
together
patrick hall says many of the
contemporary debates and theoretical
physics
are very complicated to lay people such
as myself
the only thing us lay people can do is
trust the experts but many of the
experts disagree with each other
how should we delay people go about
taking sides on issues within
theoretical physics
the other question is from alexander
cordova who says what is your process
for obtaining reliable information about
politics
social issues etc it sometimes feels
like a full-time job's worth of work to
just stay reasonably informed
due to the sheer amount of information
that we have access to nowadays
and the increasingly polarized political
climate we live in i was wondering if
you had any thoughts about this or if
you could discuss how you're able to
stay informed
while also having time for your actual
job so here we have two different sides
of a similar question namely how does
one
develop credences or beliefs or opinions
in a world where one is not an expert
and the experts disagree
right so this is a question for
non-physicists talking to people like me
or for people like me thinking about
politics or economics or
whatever so i think you know obviously i
do
think that listening to experts is
important i think that experts generally
know things
and if you don't know anything if you're
a true non-expert
and there is a consensus among experts
that says one thing
then not a hundred percent but you
should put a very high credence
on that consensus uh simply because
they're experts right i think that's a
perfectly fair thing to do again
not a hundred percent and if you have
good reasons if you're not completely
uninformed
if you have good reasons to doubt the
experts then do that but if you don't
if you literally know nothing about a
field then your default should be
to give most of your credence to what
the consensus of experts is
but of course both questions here are in
the trickier situation where the experts
do not have a consensus then what do you
do
well then you have to like keep your
wits about you a little bit and i think
that there's two things to do one is
to listen to the actual reasoning right
i mean i think this is something that
can be done
even if you're not an expert sometimes
so people say two different things
in some technical field and you say well
why
why do you believe that and sometimes
not always but sometimes it is possible
that even if you're not an expert you
can listen to their reasoning
and go oh yeah that's the kind of
reasoning that i'm sympathetic to
or oh no that reasoning sounds like
completely backwards to me even though
i'm not an expert
so sometimes you're lucky about that
like if you say why
do you not like the many world's
interpretation of quantum mechanics
and someone says well it bugs me to
think that
there are other copies of me out there
in the multiverse or even
or or if they say something like well
it's just not falsifiable because i
can't see all those other universes
and maybe you have enough expertise to
go no i don't i don't really like those
kinds of reasoning so i'm not going to
listen to you or to be fair
if someone said i like the many worlds
interpretation because
it's a very very simple underlying
ontology even though it predicts lots of
universes
and maybe you can personally say nope i
don't find that kind of reasoning
very uh persuasive myself so you can try
to do that
the other thing if you're not so lucky
as to be able to sort of
have a feeling about their process and
evidence
even if you don't have a feeling about
their conclusion
is listen to how they frame
the controversy right so regardless of
particular subject matter field
some people are just more trustworthy
than others
right uh and it's regardless of
expertise
also i mean there are people who are
super duper experts but not trustworthy
and vice versa so when you talk to
people and
they're sort of giving you the sales
pitch for believing something
um listen to you know how much do they
understand the alternatives to their
point of view are they simply dismissing
those alternatives are they being fair
are they straw manning the alternatives
are they saying well here are the
weaknesses in my view but here's why
it's nevertheless okay
or are they hiding those weaknesses from
you right there's a bunch of habits a
bunch of traits that you can pick out
as trustworthy in different people
even if you are not uh in possession of
the expert knowledge that they have
neither one of these techniques is 100
reliable and that's why life is hard
sorry can't help you there sometimes we
have to make leaps
into beliefs of some sort or another all
right
jorge uh says uh what are the main
obstacles or difficulties in quantizing
gravity i think i already did that one i
should have grouped that one sorry
um good i do have another group of
questions here
rasmus case nirbeck says particles have
anti-particles but the force carrying
particles are their own antiparticle
i've always struggled to get a mental
picture of this
trilobite tarc says looking back at your
quite enjoyable and helpful summer
series
when you talk about fermions and bosons
is it correct or too simplistic to say
that since bosons can share locations
that accumulations of bosons can account
for forces
and brian brunswick says there's a
common illustration of the rarity weak
force interactions that neutrinos would
pass
half past through several light years of
lead but what about the same question
for gravitational waves how much
interaction is there with matter
so all of these questions all these
three questions have something to do
with
the basic question of forces which is
sort of a
macroscopic kind of human scale question
versus particles like bosons and
fermions right
and how do you get these macroscopic
forces out of individual little
particles
so to the middle question yes
the thing that you and i perceive as a
classical force
electromagnetism gravity or whatever in
the language of particles
is just an accumulation of individual
particles on top of each other
and bosons can accumulate and therefore
give rise to big classical forces
whereas fermions cannot accumulate
that's why we do not have
fermion forces noticeable in the real
world but it's a fuzzy boundary so
sometimes particle physicists will talk
about forces from the exchange of
fermions and what they mean is
that two particles can interact by
exchanging fermions so for example two
photons can
bounce off of each other can scatter by
exchanging electrons and positrons
uh it's a very weak thing you need very
high energy photons to see it but
in some sense that's kind of like a
force what it's not is a big macroscopic
force that we could notice in the real
world the bosonic nature
of photons and gravitons is very
important for creating
those big macroscopic forces um to the
first question
the the you have been told that
particles have their own antiparticles
but you've just been lied to
some particles have their own
antiparticles and some don't
the the idea of anti-matter is a
convenient kind of classification in
some cases but it's not a fundamental
idea when you have particles that carry
some conserved quantity like electric
charge
then they will have anti-particles a
charged particle with a positive charge
will always have a negatively charged
anti-particle
but for particles like photons uh they
don't have their own anti-particles they
or or sometimes you will hear people say
they are their own
anti-particles okay and the same would
be true for just a single
you could imagine a single fermion that
didn't have its own
antiparticle you're allowed to imagine
that possibility well we just don't know
of any in nature that are like that
so when you get into it when you get
into it a little bit more deeply what
matters is
what the charges are what the symmetries
are and what the interactions are
between the different particles this
particle and antiparticle
classification doesn't always fit
reality very well
sorry about that sorry i've been
misleading you for all these times i do
it myself
um and about the passing through
neutrinos or gravitons passing through
uh light years of lead gravitons
individual gravitons
interact much more weakly than neutrinos
do so if you're literally talking about
a collection
of gravitons they would pass right
through lead no worries
the difference is as we just talked
about gravitons can pile on top of each
other they're bosons unlike neutrinos
which are fermions and so gravitons can
give rise to big macroscopic
classical force fields or classical
excitations in the gravitational field
so
classical gravitational waves can be
thought of as a huge
number of gravitons piling on top of
each other so in principle
a gravitational wave passing through
matter would be distorted by it it would
lose energy because it would try to
squeeze the matter a little bit and pass
energy onto it
and indeed that that process is at the
heart of how we can detect them
uh but you need a lot of gravitons piled
on top of each other to make that a
noticeable
thing if you're talking about individual
gravitons versus individual neutrinos
individual gravitons will pass through
matter much quickly much
much more easily than even neutrinos
will
okay josh says a field like biology can
have moral implications for example
discovering which species feel pain do
you think that anything we've learned in
the field of physics has implications
for
morality and there's a related question
that i'll
ask here p walder says at this year's
darwin day lecture
oliver scott curry presented data from
twin studies
showing that the moral qualities of
kinship mutualism exchange heroism etc
are encoded in our deen
in our genes data was also presented for
60 different cultures showing that the
same moral qualities were universal
across the cultures assuming these data
are replicable
should we now consider that ought can be
derived from
is so um in both cases let me let me do
the second question first
no this is zero evidence that ought can
be derived from is
you literally just mentioned a whole
bunch of things that are is-is
people behave uh heroically
people show deference people feel
kinship right and these are encoded in
our genes that's an is
that's a fact about the world okay
there's nothing in
our genes or our behavior that lets us
then
say oh and this is how we ought to
behave
right that's the question of morality if
you presuppose
that kinship and heroism etc are good
are things that we ought to do then
these genetic studies show us that these
good
behaviors that we ought to have are in
our genes right and in fact
this is a well-known argument against
moral realism
because people say look there's
something that evolves right there's
some there's some
pressure to reproduce under the rules of
natural selection to pass on our genes
to future generations
and there is also something that is
right and wrong why in the world should
they
match up why in the world should they
agree uh i mean if you thought that
there was some pre-existing objective
morality
why should natural selection ever find
that when natural selection just wants
to make us survive
uh so the inability to derive ought from
is is simply a logical impossibility
right ought is a different property than
is
it can't be derived from it so there's
no evidence it will ever change my mind
this is you know
you cannot add two even numbers together
and get an odd number no matter how many
mathematical
uh experiments you end up doing
so likewise the previous question do you
think that uh
what we've learned in the field of
physics has implications for for
morality
here it depends on what you mean by
implications because
you begin the question josh begins this
question with biology can have moral
implications for example discovering
which species feel
pain discovering which species feel
pain doesn't have implications for
meta ethics meta ethics being the job
of justifying one's moral principles
right
um pain exists i feel pain if i
discovered that earthworms felt pain
that would have zero impact on the way
that i justify my moral principles
it might have an impact on how i behave
if i
already had a moral principle that said
pain is bad and i should try to minimize
it in the world okay
so sure physics can absolutely have
implications for how we behave in the
world given what our moral principles
are
physics helps us build bombs okay so i
should not act in a certain way to build
a bomb and drop it on people if i think
that's morally wrong
but these discoveries in neither physics
nor biology
directly affect what i take to be the
moral rules that i live my life by
okay hilbert spaceman says probably not
their given name
suppose we have a two-state quantum
system for which the born rule predicts
equal probability to measure the system
in either state
if an experimenter were to get the same
measurement a million times in a row
would this be considered an experimental
violation of the born rule and if so how
does one experimentally test the born
rule um
it's you can't violate the bourne rule
uh in quite that clear-cut away
right uh as i think you probably felt as
you were typing this question you know
if
if you have a prediction via the born
rule that a certain system and
experiment will give you 50 50 answers
spin up and spin down and you get spin
up
five times in a row you go huh that's
pretty rare
and if you get it ten times in a row
you're thinking wow that's really rare
and if you get it a hundred times in a
row it's more rare and a million times
is more rare so
it never passes some threshold to go oh
the born rule is wrong
but as a good bayesian what you should
be doing is saying well
there's a certain credence i give to the
born rule being right
there's a certain credence i give to the
born rule being wrong
and the more data i collect of all these
spins being up when the bourne rule
predicted that there'll be 50 50.
the more i deviate from the prediction
of the born rule
the lower my credence is that the born
rule becomes
is should be accepted right that the
born rule is right
so it's exactly the same as with
anything else look if i say
i have newton's inverse square law of
gravity
here near the earth in the
non-relativistic regime places where
it was all you know newton's laws of
gravity are very very well tested right
uh could i imagine doing an experiment
that seems incompatible with newtonian
gravity
sure maybe i just make a mistake right
like maybe my experimental setup isn't
very good
so you never just do an experiment go up
i ruled out
my theory you change your credence in
your theory and you change that
gradually this is what a good bayesian
does
and it applies just as well to the born
rule as to anything else
greg griffiths says about your
ruminations on the philosophy of
mathematics a few months ago what issues
do you personally find
most in need of thought in that field
so we will have podcasts coming up by
the philosophy of mathematics
um honestly the most basic dumb
questions are the ones that i
am struggling with uh what is real right
to what extent do we think of
mathematical structures as
real like a platonist would do or a
mathematical realist more
generally my my uh
inclination is to say that there are
senses in which
mathematical things are real but not the
same sentence the
tables and chairs are real but honestly
you know the real philosophers of
mathematics
they've thought through all this stuff
and this is a perfect example of a place
where i'm not an expert
so i'm trying to listen to them and
listen to them is hard because again
they don't agree with each other right
as we said
before this is me i'm trying to apply my
criteria uh to the experts i'm reading
the experts and i'm you know
trying to find the ones that on the one
hand you know overlap with my beliefs in
other areas and on the other hand seem
trustworthy you know seem honest
about what they're doing and who give
reasons that i find compelling that's
what i'm trying to do
sam says what are your thoughts on
cornell west's current situation at
harvard
so for those of you who don't know
cornell west previous podcast guest um
is a professor at harvard but in a
special position that is not
uh technically a tenured position at
harvard he used to be tenured at harvard
in fact
like a big university professor kind of
job and he left
because he was insulted by larry summers
who was the president at the time
he went to princeton and then he moved
back and i i have zero knowledge of
all the twists and turns in that saga
and i have zero knowledge
of what harvard is saying um but
uh it's in the news recently because
apparently
uh he wants to be he wants to have that
tenured
uh label attached to his current
position and harvard is reluctant to do
it and
so people are you know people have their
opinions about this so i don't have
opinions about that specific situation
and as a general rule it's not always
true but as a rough guide
i try not to comment
on individual people's employment
situations
at institutions that i don't know much
about because
you don't know i mean it's it's a it's
the kind of thing you can easily
um ride that those kinds of
controversies for your own political
purposes
but in fact uh there's usually about a
billion factors going into these
discussions that you're not aware of
because you're not there
right and not all the facts come to
light not all the parties involved
have any interests in sharing uh all the
features that they're talking about
um so you don't know and maybe you
should just be quiet about it so
i'm gonna be quiet about the actual
facts
uh of cornell west's current situation
we can think more broadly about the kind
of
situation right where we can abstract
away from his personal
situation you know what if you have
someone like cornell west who is clearly
um accomplished in their field
uh has also been extremely active
in a more public sphere right so i think
that it's fair to say that
the one of the reasons why there is some
resistance
to giving tenure to someone like cornell
west these days even though there
wouldn't have been
20 or 30 years ago is because a lot of
his work is sort of more public facing
than traditional um and scholarly
right and you know referee journals and
things like that
so what should the role be of people
like that
there's of course a whole huge extra set
of considerations because cornell west
is
a very very famous african-american
scholar and there are black students at
harvard who says like
he's our guy and you will really be
treating us badly if you do not try
your best to keep him right i take all
of those uh
arguments very seriously i think that's
true i think representation matters
uh role models matter all that stuff but
but but again i'm not enough of an
expert to opine intelligently on that
so when it comes to you know what do you
do about people
who i mean you can probably guess my
answer here right but
what what do you do about people who uh
who've been doing most of their work in
a more public-facing way than in the
traditional academic
uh channels you know i'm in favor of
those people guess what
you know i i i try to do both myself um
and not because i think it's the best
for my career but because that's what i
enjoy doing like i take real true
pleasure in writing papers
technical papers for referee journals in
the very standard academic way
but it's not the only thing i take
pleasure in doing i do things like what
i'm doing very at this very moment which
is much more
public-facing so i'm a big believer in a
diverse ecosystem
when it comes to this stuff i think that
a good university
uh should not devote all of its faculty
positions
purely a hundred percent to people whose
noses are to the grindstone in the
academic
treadmill writing papers for referee
journals etc that stuff is important
but it's not uniquely important there
are other things that are also important
i mean
say what you will about cornell west you
cannot accuse him of not working hard
i mean the man puts in the hours right
uh
you know even if it's kind of adorable i
don't even know if you know
but he doesn't use a laptop so when we
had him on the podcast
he uses an ipad um i don't know he
probably doesn't know how to type but
you know he must he must know how to
type because he gets a lot of books
written
but uh yeah he uses an ipad so we had to
like figure out what the right
microphone and software was to do the
podcast is but he was willing to do it
like he's all right help me figure this
out
um very prolific he has his own podcast
um
he's done he is he has done the academic
growing kind of work
i'm a hundred percent in favor of people
like
cornell west being tenured professors
again you wouldn't want
every tenured professor to be like that
but you wouldn't want all the tenure
professors to be stuck in their offices
doing their
work for the 12 other people in their
field either you need
both and so you know in terms of
places like harvard devoting
some tiny fraction of their resources
to professors who are hugely influential
public figures doing interdisciplinary
work being good role models stuff like
that
yes i think that's kind of important
ashley hyatt says
can you explain how hawking radiation
causes a black hole to shrink
if only one particle from a pair created
linear near the horizon is emitted as
radiation isn't the other one consumed
by the black hole thus
increasing its mass um yes the other one
is
consumed by the black hole but there's a
trick of general relativity so you know
i don't know where you are in your
education ashley but if you ever get to
read my graduate textbook on general
relativity
space time and geometry what you will
learn is
you can define the energy of a particle
as seen by different observers this is a
feature of relativity
okay so that different reference frames
if you want to put it that way or
different observers located different
places
will define what you mean by
the energy of a particle differently and
in particular
when you're close to a black hole in
general relativity where space and time
are being warped
that difference can be pretty big so it
turns out that if you were
at the horizon if somehow and this is
not actually possible but if you could
imagine
seeing these two particles a particle
and an anti-particle being created one
goes
out and one goes in and as you're
falling through the horizon
you would see both of them as ordinary
positive mass particles
but from the point of view someone who's
very very far away
they attribute a negative energy
a negative mass effectively to the
particle that falls in
so yes the black hole to the point of
view an outside observer the black hole
is absorbing a particle but it's
absorbing a particle with a negative
energy
so the total energy of the black hole
goes down and of course
the energy that it's absorbing the
negative energy it's absorbing is
exactly the same
in magnitude as the positive energy of
the particle that's emitted so all the
math works out
surprise surprise you're probably not
surprised all the math actually does
work out
okay two questions i'm going to group
together sandro stuckey says could you
tell us a little bit about your
podcasting setup
what type of hardware and software do
you use you said at some point that you
send mics to the guests
would you mind telling us what type of
mic those are and steve louderbox says
you've mentioned you send a microphone
to guests so share with us the
manufacturer
and name of that microphone so yeah
short version here
if you go to the podcast homepage
preposterousuniverse.compodcast
one of the you know there's all sorts of
goodies there i encourage you to check
it out one of the things on the
right-hand column
is about mindscape you can click there
and you can find the complete
description of my podcasting setup i've
typed that in and there's also these
links to buy it uh so my
microphone is what is called an electro
electro voice
re320 it's a very nice
um voice microphone you know it's not
you know
it's not going to be um a good studio
microphone for a professional musician
but for podcasters it's just about
perfect i think um and for those i don't
know how
up you are on microphone technology but
the big
decision to make if you're a potential
podcaster and you're looking at
microphones is
the wiring believe it or not i mean
there's other decisions to make because
there's like condensers versus dynamic
microphones
and etc but okay really the wiring
matters because there are usb
microphones that you just plug right
into your computer
no worries right but there's also xlr
microphones so the xlr cable is a
different cable it's not usb not at all
usb it's a more professional
audio quality kind of cable okay and so
the higher end microphones will tend to
be xlr microphones
not usb microphones therefore
my microphone is an xlr microphone i
cannot plug it directly into my computer
and i knew this going in it's not a
surprise
um so what you do is you plug it into a
recorder or a mixer
okay so the standard in the podcast land
is something called a zoom
recorder nothing to do with zoom the
online video thing but there's only so
many
names you can have for your company so
there there's a very nice company that
makes
small recording devices to which you can
plug in xlr microphones and so it's both
like
a recorder in and of itself and also
an interface for your mic and then you
can attach
the zoom to your computer via usb
i have a slightly higher level thing
which is called a
mix pre-3 made by sound devices and it's
a little tiny
mixer okay so i can plug several
microphones in
three in fact microphones and they have
their separate
volume controls gain controls and i can
also plug in the computer
to the mix pre and i can get an input
from there
so usually when i'm actually recording a
podcast i have my microphone
plugged into the mix pre 3 being
recorded in the left hand
channel of the stereo mix and i have the
guest coming into the computer which is
then plugged into the mix pre-three
going into the right-hand
channel but i don't actually use that
guest
audio for the podcast because i re
record using
zencaster and zencaster will record the
guest
locally themselves and then transfer the
file to me so
i can download from my mix pre the
stereo version of what i recorded with
both my voice and their voice
and then i take from zencaster just
their voice
and i go into this program called
audacity which i
it's either free or it's anyway it's
public um but it's a
you know it's a it's a for your computer
and you do all the audio mixing
from there noise reduction compression
all of those things and so i
if you listen to the early podcast i was
not very good at that i'm still not
great at it but i'm better than i was
at the beginning uh so then i can line
up
the file that i get from zencaster in
time you can shift it right right and
left so i
line up the guest's audio from zencaster
with the guest's audio that i recorded
and then i can delete
the guest audio that i recorded so that
the time sync is right but the audio
quality is better because i'm getting it
directly from zencaster so the voice
that you hear
in from the guest in my podcast did not
come over the internet
uh before it was recorded recorded
directly there at their house
so i'm not gonna i mean this stuff is
too expensive i'm not gonna mail it all
to them
what i generally mail to the guests is a
blue yeti
usb microphone so you don't want the
guest to do too much work
the blue yeti is a very very standard
microphone it cost about 100 bucks
they went through a period when we first
entered quarantine they became very
expensive because everyone was starting
a podcast
because what else are you gonna do um
but a blue yeti is a wonderful
microphone
it is the standard for very good reasons
it's plug and play plug into your
uh computer um and
push the button and there it goes and it
records quite well
not as well as my re 320
or my mix pre3 they're recording from a
blue yeti directly into their computer
so
inevitably my video my audio uh sounds a
little bit better
okay but uh so be it um
and then what was i gonna say yeah so
then i think that um if you're a
starting out podcaster
you could just start with the blue yeti
uh yourself oh i remember what i want to
say
thank you thank you once again to all
the patreon uh
uh folks out there because you you know
and of course also the ads that appear
on the non-patreon version of the
podcast but it's
your contributions that let me buy
microphones and send them like the
guests are always very very happy
that they get a microphone uh for free
for appearing on the podcast because i
you know i don't ask them to send it
back i try to minimize work
for my guests right so it's a gift keep
the microphone
use it for the next podcast you want to
be on so gradually i am improving the
sound quality of everyone's podcasts
i should give credit also to sam harris
who actually gave me the idea for
sending
uh microphones to people but you folks
the patreon supporters
are paying for it in some very real
sense you're paying for that you're
paying for the transcripts of every
episode all the stuff costs money
and i do it because there are people who
care enough about the podcast to give me
money to do it
so i want to make the quality as high as
i can for all of you folks so thank you
another podcast question comes from
matthew o'connor
what is your process with a typical
guest before recording starts do you do
a warm-up call do you go in cold do you
send them an outline of points you'd
like to hit
um don't do many of these things at all
no i think that
i try to get people high-quality people
as guests on the podcast
they're usually very busy i try to make
their
burden minimal try to do very little
to ask them to do things other than the
actual interview
i do let them suggest things to talk
about if they have you know
there's some subset of all the things
that they've done in their life
that they're very interested in talking
about right now then i'm very happy to
take those suggestions
but there's no warm-up call there's no
outline or anything like that
you know i am trying to get better at
being the interviewer on the podcast i
uh probably over prepared when i first
started you know had a whole list of
questions planned out
and i think that to make it more of an
organic conversation these days i try to
go in with
you know a couple two three four main
points i want to hit
maybe a little um a couple of things
that i've read or heard in their stuff
that
is a sufficiently fun anecdote that i
want to bring up
but otherwise try to let the
conversation be the conversation i'm
still not as good at that
as i would like to be but that is
definitely the goal
and like i said the guests are busy
people and i want to make their burden
as
light as possible in my view the guests
are being incredibly generous by
offering their time to be on the podcast
so i don't want them to do any work
to do it peter bamber says if a proton
is made of quarks which themselves are
disturbances in quantum fields
what does it mean to refer to the
diameter of a proton
well it is a necessarily fuzzy concept
the diameter of a proton you know these
fields have profiles roughly speaking
that's a slightly overly classical
notion but maybe you know what i mean
um and it's sort of like saying what is
the width of a bell curve distribution
right the bell curve gaussian
distribution never
hits zero no matter how far you go away
from it but you can talk about
the width that half of its size right
half of its amplitude
so there's other ways of talking about
sizes of things that don't really have
any well-defined boundary
that's what it is for the proton you
know where do the fields
fall off sufficiently far that you
wouldn't say that you were in the proton
anymore something like that
samuel benjamin says are you aware of
any evidence that as humans we try to
fix the world around us into a highly
organized
lower entropy state because we like to
make order from the chaos
i'm thinking specifically about efforts
being put into highly coordinated
integr interconnected smart energy
networks across the uk
these are super complex to design no one
really has an effective way of doing it
wouldn't we be better off having more
localized energy networks that are far
less effort to design
i.e higher entropy um
you you i think that you're on to
something here but i'm not sure if i
would use exactly
that terminology or necessarily that
motivation
um i don't think that human beings are
trying to just be as organized as
possible
what i try what i think is that human
beings you know
when human beings design things it is an
example of intelligent design
it is different than things growing up
organically
and i think that the real issue with
things like that is not that they're
too complicated or too simple or too
global or too local it's that
when we design things there's a whole
bunch of factors that go in one of which
is
ease of being comprehended by us right
we need to be able to look at it and fix
it
um and another thing that goes in is we
can imagine a certain set of
circumstances
that would qualify as as disasters right
as bad as failure modes for the system
we're looking at
and we're less imaginative in some sense
than nature is
so since nature does not design uh
for specific purposes we end up with
organisms that are just more
multi-purpose and in a sense
much more flexible much more able to
adapt
to unforeseen circumstances
but i don't think that uh it's
necessarily the right thing to
say well we need more localized energy
networks i think that it'd be nice to
have
more um robust energy networks and grids
and things like that but that might end
up being
a higher entropy or low entropy or i'm
not i'm not quite sure what i think that
that is not necessarily as far as i know
the right criterion to have in mind in a
case like this
victor alejandro weiner says i grew up
in the 60s in argentina in a family of
writers painters and actors
as a child and then as a young man i had
the strong feeling that if you were a
fan of the sciences there was nothing
for you in the arts and vice versa
later i saw this attitude ease thanks in
no small part to the hofstadters
sagans and so on does this fit with your
personal experience at all did you ever
feel that you needed to choose
um no i don't actually i don't really
think so i never you know look
i did not grow up in a family of either
scientists or
artists and writers i grew up you know
in people who were working as
secretaries and
sales people and steel workers and so
forth so there was no science versus
arts dialogue going on
in the house that i was growing up in
and honestly i never i mean i know
you're referring to i get it i have seen
it later in life
but i never worried about that i never
thought that oh i need to be either
artsy or sciency or something like that
that wasn't a
a bifurcation that i was aware of at the
time in order to fret about
steve pelling says according to pbs
space time
gravity is due to the local time slowing
effect due to the
effective mass on space time this is
mind-blowing can you discuss this and
how it explains the gravity acceleration
equivalence principle
i'm probably not going to exactly
explain what you want me to explain let
me say a few words
about this for one thing there is no
local time-slowing effect as i said
right at the beginning of the podcast
that is not the way to think about it
what there is in general relativity is a
metric
on space-time which is a way of relating
uh
different curves in space-time which
could either be literally a curve
through space that you draw on the
ground or a curve through time like the
trajectory of a particle or something
like that
and the metric tells you the length of
these curves if the curves
extend mostly through space it will tell
you the spatial length if the curves
extend mostly through time it will tell
you the time elapsed
on such a curve and you know this thing
that you're calling
that probably pbs space time also called
uh the local time
slowing effect is exactly a comparison
that you shouldn't be doing
between a clock that is in deep in a
gravitational field and a clock that is
far away okay it's not a comparison you
should make because
time is measured locally and you should
only compare elapsed time long
trajectories that start and end at the
same
events but but i know what you mean
there is a
metric on space-time that has a form
that depends on the distance that you
are away from some gravitating
object and furthermore the way that
the actual metric of space-time works in
general relativity
there's sort of two factors that come in
there's a factor that multiplies the
time coordinate
and there's a factor that multiplies the
spatial coordinates
and here's what they're getting at
here's the actual thing that they're
trying to say
um you might think that gravity if you
ever think about all those pictures
of general relativity with like a rubber
sheet with a bowling ball or whatever
right bending space around it you might
think that the gravitational field that
we feel
is mostly due to this
stretching of space not the stretching
of time like
time isn't being bent in these rubber
sheet examples right
but that's not true the the reality is
that if you think about
your trajectory through space-time
you're traveling much slower than the
speed of light right
so in some very real quantifiable sense
you are traveling more through time
than through space you're not moving
that fast through space and you're
moving one second per second
through time so it turns out that it's
the warping of
the time component in the metric that is
actually more
responsible for gravity in the newtonian
limit
the inverse square law of gravity the
fact that apples fall from trees the
fact that you do not float away from the
earth
this is mostly because of the warping of
that time
coordinate that time-like direction now
i would be reluctant to allow you
to sort of extend this in any
simple-minded way
to how you experience time or
acceleration or the equivalence
principle or any of those other things
it is just a true fact about the
newtonian limit
of general relativity and the fact that
you're moving slowly compared to the
speed of light you
feel the warping of time more than the
warping of space that's really all it is
it's not even that important i wouldn't
make too big a deal of it
john lownsberry says as quantum
computers move from theoretical to
practical applications can you envision
any ways in which their computations
could actually help solve
other quantum mysteries uh yeah sure
it's definitely possible to imagine
indeed that was the big motivation that
richard feynman had when he was one of
the first people to
discuss quantum computers and basically
if you want to
simulate a quantum mechanical system
what better place to do it than in
another quantum mechanical
system you don't have to do it we can
simulate the wave function and the
schrodinger equation on classical
computers
but quantum computers are sort of
tailor-made for that kind of thing
so whether it's things like chemistry or
you know down at the single molecule
level how do different molecules come
together to do chemical reactions
or quantum field theory uh my cal tech
colleague john preschool and his friends
have done a lot of work on
simulating quantum field theories with
quantum computers
uh i'm not an expert on any of those
things but if you if you want to know
whether quantum computers will be used
to solve quantum problems the answer is
yes uh you say quantum mysteries say the
mysteries in quantum mechanics are more
like
the foundational questions right the
measurement problem the reality problem
i don't think the quantum computers are
going to say anything about those things
but they will
help us do practical calculations
daniele cortese says what do you think
about penrose's argument that
consciousness
is not a computation uh well i do not
agree
with it i mean i i get it i get where
it's coming from
you know there is this argument from
girdle's theorem essentially or even i
guess from turing
that uh there's some things that
computations can't do
right there's some things that uh you
can't reach axiomatically
on the basis of some axioms and then do
computations on the axioms to prove
theorems
there are conclusions you can't reach in
that axiomatic way
according to what we know about logic
and mathematics
whereas it seems that human beings can
reach conclusions so you know girdle's
theorem says if you have a sufficiently
powerful formal system
then there are statements in that formal
system that
cannot be proven if the system is
consistent so either the system is
inconsistent and you can end up proving
it
or this seems consistent and you can't
prove it in which case maybe it's true
but you can't prove it and you get into
sort of philosophy of math questions
very very quickly um whereas penrose and
others would say look
i can see that statement i can just look
at it and i know it's true even though
the formal system
and therefore a computer can't prove it
well the question is and scott aronson
who previously appeared on the podcast
uh is the one who basically taught me
this you know
how do you know that that formal system
is
consistent right we think it's
consistent but do you know
like how do you prove that have you
proven it um
and a computer you could just say well
you know
let's assume it's consistent and see
what we get out of that right
um i don't i think that the human brain
is physical
right i think that uh we're sloppy
thinkers our human brains and we can
often
attribute certainty to some of our uh
thoughts that are in fact
don't deserve to have certainty
attributed to them and therefore it can
lead
us to believe that we've quote unquote
reached conclusions
that a rigorous algorithmic computer
wouldn't
but i think that's just giving us too
much credit honestly
horstworst says what is your opinion on
black heterodox public intellectuals
like john mcwhorter or coleman hughes do
you share their concerns regarding
critical race theory or identical
identity politics
uh no i don't generally share their
concerns
um also i should say i don't have great
familiarity with either one of them
uh what they're i i know who they are i
was on coleman hughes's podcast
uh but i don't know their work in any
detail
um i am a big believer in the existence
of heterodox
public intellectuals in a very similar
vein to what i just said
about people like cornell west i do
think that there's uh
you know there's usefulness in pluralism
and variety
in intellectual life we talked about
this on the podcast with musa
al ghabri you know it's just good to
have a whole bunch of different ideas
out there so i'm all in favor of people
like john mcwhorter and coleman hughes
existing having said that let me say two
other things one is you know there's an
obvious bias at work here
that people can fall into if you're not
black if you're a white person
and you kind of are rubbed the wrong way
by black people
going around saying you know we've been
oppressed we've been discriminated
against there's a legacy of slavery
there still exists
biases and discrimination a lot of white
people
are defensive about that and so
when they can find a black person who
says oh no no it's more black people's
fault than white people's fault which is
it i know a dramatic oversimplification
but for the this thought experiment
there's a huge bias that you can fall
into
in saying ah you're a good black person
you're saying what i want to hear
let me talk to you and elevate your
opinions this is not a criticism of the
opinions
themselves this is a criticism of who's
listening to the opinions and who is
giving them voice etc you know
and again not to say that these opinions
are the wrong ones
but you should be very very wary
about your own vices right your own uh
biases
your own ability to want to hear certain
things
and to uh agree when the people you're
talking to
say the things you want to hear i think
that it's more important
to be confronting and to be facing the
opinions you don't want to hear
right um so i think that it's important
that we have
uh heterodox black public intellectuals
but also
it's super important arguably more
important that we take seriously what
the more orthodox
black public intellectuals are saying
that we don't want to hear if we
we in the sense of white people uh who
might be
might take some of what they say as
criticism right that's what we have to
face up to
the other thing is you know i have a
complicated relationship with the word
heterodox
you know uh because i do believe in
pluralism and i do believe that
there's a lot of questions to which we
don't know the right answer some amount
of heterodoxy i think is important
heterodoxy being not being orthodox
right you know going against
the tide but i believe that because i
believe in pluralism not because i
believe that heterodoxy
by itself is a virtue you know there's a
very thin line between saying you know
i'm heterodox i don't fall into the
establishment man
and just being a crackpot right or just
valorizing heterodoxy like you know the
heterodox academy
is a whole thing and i would never want
to belong to something called the
heterodox academy because
i don't value being heterodox i value
being correct
and i worry that there's a whole again a
temptation a bias whatever you want to
call it
to valorize being anti-establishment
for the sake of being anti-establishment
not for the sake of being correct
sometimes you've got to be
anti-establishment because
you think it's correct that i'm all in
favor of
but as soon as you sort of start taking
pleasure in being naughty and contrarian
just for the sake of being naughty and
contrarian
that's equally bad of a vice or a bias
or a mistake
as it would be to just always go along
with the orthodoxy right
that's why intellectual life is hard
because there's a balance you have to be
able to strike
between listening to experts knowing
what the orthodoxy is
trying to understand what they're saying
and also be willing
to be heterodox and anti-establishment
when you think it's the right thing to
do
okay that's a really really difficult
balance to get right i struggle with it
everyone struggles with it
so i'm all in favor of the existence of
black heterodox public intellectuals
along with the orthodox ones
and we all white black yellow purple
whatever
have the difficult task ahead of us of
listening to all of them
and listening to them for the value in
what they're saying
not because they happen to be saying
what we do or do not want to hear johnny
says
frank wilcheck spoke recently with sam
harris and said something to the effect
of
it is enough to make the calculations in
quantum physics and the interpretation
of what is happening is basically
semantics
is this actually the prominent view in
the field uh it's certainly a prominent
view i mean a lot of people
think that i mean maybe probably you
might be right uh i'm not you but the
question might be
uh the answer might be yes uh that it's
the
most prominent view in the field it
always depends on how you define the
field right
it's obviously not the prominent view
among people who
specialize in foundations of quantum
mechanics but then there's obviously
also a huge selection effect like if you
thought that was the right view you
would not specialize in the foundations
of quantum mechanics it's like
most philosophers are atheists but most
philosophers of religion are not
right okay that's that least surprising
thing in the world if you're an atheist
probably not going to specialize in
philosophy of religion
if you think that the interpretation is
basically semantics you're not going to
specialize in the foundations of quantum
mechanics
i disagree obviously um i have thought
about this
carefully i think and uh other people
also thought about it carefully and i
completely wildly dramatically
disagree that the uh uh interpretation
is just
semantics there's there are physical
questions is the wave function a
representation of reality
or is it just a represent a
calculational tool that we use to make
predictions that's a question i can't
even imagine
thinking that that question is somehow
basically semantics it's a question
about the fundamental nature of reality
are there hidden variables are there
objective wave function collapses
are there branches into other universes
these are all direct physical
real questions that are certainly not
semantics and you know i know perfectly
well that frank and others have
these points of view and so i had him on
the podcast and we didn't talk about
that
and you know i i don't want to talk
about that stuff with
frank wilcheck because frank wolcheck
has made enormously big contributions
in a bunch of really creative ways to
all sorts of interesting questions in
fundamental physics
i want to talk about that with him i do
not consider
i know this wasn't your question johnny
but let me just say it anyway
um i mean again part of why i'm picking
certain questions to
answer here is because they spark in me
other things i want to say
um so i you know i don't bring people on
the podcast to debate them
uh i certainly do not bring people on
the podcast to
ride my hobby horses and uh you know
confront them with my opinions about
things about which we might disagree
when i bring people on the podcast i
want them to look
good i want the people who are listening
to the podcast
to say oh yes i see why this person is
an interesting person to listen to
whether or not i agree with them
i'm very happy to bring people i
disagree on the podcast
um but i want to disagree with them in a
way that is potentially
profitable potentially constructive that
i can learn something from them even if
i disagree with them
and mostly they're there on the podcast
to say their spiel
not to listen to me you know the total
number of words i've said on the podcast
over 130 some episodes is way bigger
than any of the guests
so i don't need to you know spend the
whole time talking to frank wilceck
writing my hobby horses about the
foundations of quantum mechanics i would
much rather
learn from him about particle physics
and his views of fundamental physics
today
just in case you were wondering why did
not give him a hard time about the
foundations of quantum theory
okay so i have another group of three
questions
uh yes anders says in your interview
with brian greene he mentioned that some
people suspect that string theory might
not allow for a positive cosmological
constant after
all let's say that that's definitely
true would you say
what is more probable a string theory is
wrong
or b the cause of the universe's
acceleration is not a cosmological
constant so that's one question
daniel westwater says i was wondering
why dark energy is known to be the cause
of the expansion of the universe
increasing the speed of galaxies moving
apart but seems like it's only in empty
space
why don't we see dark energy and effects
in galaxies themselves
and the third question is you often
mention sorry from david to cloat
you often mentioned that the cosmos
constant is the best candidate for what
the dark energy is
i can see how a constant in a formula
can describe what dark energy does
but how does that explain anything how
can it be dark energy
uh so yeah let's go i should have
ordered these better once again let's do
the last one first here
um the cosmological constant it that's a
label
right okay uh so yes it is true that i
have said and i continue to believe that
the cosmos constant is the best
candidate for what dark energy is
but the phrase cosmological constant is
a label for
what is alternatively known as the
vacuum energy
it's the energy inherent in empty space
itself it's a thing it's not just a
number in a formula
it's a real thing it's the energy of
empty space in every cubic centimeter
of space if there's no stuff there no
particles no radiation or whatever you
can still ask how much
energy it has that's a fact about empty
space itself
and that fact is the vacuum energy aka
the cosmological constant
that's how it can be dark energy it's
just an inherent property of space-time
itself
for the effect on galaxies themselves
question from daniel
well there is an effect so if you have
the cosmological constant in particular
but also if you have other forms of dark
energy
in principle that affects the motions of
the planets around the sun
it affects the motion of the stars in
the galaxy but in practice when you
calculate the numbers the effects are
really really really small
why because the amount of dark energy is
really really really small
the difference between it and other
things is that it accumulates
in effect because it's everywhere it's
literally in every cubic centimeter
okay so to see the effects of dark
energy you need to let
that effect build up which means that
it's easiest to see
when you look at galaxies very very far
away so you're really seeing the whole
expansion rate of the universe here in
the solar system in principle
the procession of mercury is affected by
the value of the cosmological constant
but
the precision to which we can measure
that is nowhere anywhere close
to what it would need to be to detect
the effect of the cosmological constant
uh finally in reverse order here for
anders's question uh
so it is possible although people don't
really have an agreement on this this is
another place on which experts disagree
is string theory compatible with a
positive cosmological constant
um i think it'd be a very good question
you know i'm i'm only you know
two two cheers for string theory not
three cheers kind of person
um i i will continue to say until i no
longer believe it that string theory is
the most
promising approach that we have on the
market now to a quantum theory of
gravity
but it doesn't mean it's right none of
the approaches are
you know home runs quite to this point
in time so string theory could easily be
wrong
if the cause of the universe's
acceleration is not a cosmodrome
constant that also
leads to other problems it leads to
problems with fifth forces
and constants of nature changing and
other new fine-tunings and so forth
so neither one of these options would be
plausible uh or sorry not plausible
neither one of these options would be
you know
easily embraced by someone like me but
that's okay you know you gotta sometimes
you're forced
to take action so i think i can't quite
answer the question
definitively if the cosmos constant were
positive
and sorry if string theory were
incompatible with the cosmos
constant would i first give up on string
theory or
uh that the acceleration of the universe
is a cosmological constant i think i
would decrease my credence in both
of those uh by a certain amount and wait
for more evidence to come in to decide
between them
angela howard says if the wave function
represents reality
and we're living in a particular branch
why do we see a wave pattern in the
unmeasured double slit experiment are we
seeing part of the wave function of the
universe
well in my way of saying it so i need to
confess different
fans of the everett interpretation will
answer this question
differently uh you know famously i think
david deutsch if if i get his view
correctly
talks about um the
two different slits that the electron
can go through as being two different
branches of the wave function in the
universe
i do not think that way at all in my way
of thinking
branches happen when quantum mechanical
systems decohere
that is to say when they become
entangled with their environment
so in my way of talking your question is
easily answered
the electron going through two different
slits is still one branch of the wave
function
okay it's doing two different things
because its wave function is spread out
but its wave function is not entangled
with anything else
that's why you can still see the
interference pattern it's not two
different branches
and honestly i'm not sure how you can
consistently hold the other point of
view i mean
if you think about a spin instead of an
electron think about it
rather than instead of the position of
the electron think of its spin
so we know that if you measure the
electron
uh its spin in a plus
z axis okay then you'll always get
either spin up or spin down those are
the only two choices
likewise if you measure it along a plus
x axis or a plus y
axis you will always get either spin up
or spin down along those
individual axes so let's say you have
an electron that you've just measured
you know it is
spin up along the x-axis okay so you
know what the
spin state is of the electron it's up
along the x-axis
but if you you can express that
in the z-axis basis and an electron that
is pointing along the x-axis
is exactly the same as an electron that
is
half pointing up along the z-axis and
half pointing down
along the z axis so with respect to the
x-axis it's a single thing
it's just pointing in the plus direction
with respect to the
z-axis it's a combination of two things
one spin-up and one spin down
so is that one branch or two i think the
answer is
it's one branch in either case because
as long as it's not entangled with the
rest of the world
it's still one branch anonymous
says could the expansion of space ever
move the earth and sun so
far apart that we all freeze or does the
local gravitational attraction of the
earth and the sun keep us safe
uh it's the latter i probably should
have grouped this with the previous
question
but the earth and the sun are not moving
apart because of the expansion of space
the existence of in fact so here's
here's something you can think about
if you had a universe that was
completely uniform right the matter
particles and let's say that they're
super duper cold dark matter particles
so they're literally zero velocity with
respect to each other just a lattice of
particles sitting there
in a universe that is expanding
perfectly smoothly distributed
so you know exactly what the solution is
an exact solution to einstein's equation
with an expanding universe
what you can do is you can take some
sphere
okay imagine some sphere that you invent
with particles inside and particles
outside
and you can take all the particles
inside and collapse them to the middle
okay so that you now have the same
number of particles you had before but
instead of being uniformly spread
they're all collapsed in let's say a
black hole or a planet or something or a
star
inside this sphere and there's a sharp
boundary
where your vacuum inside except for the
planet or star or black hole or whatever
and outside there's this uniform gas of
particles
so it turns out that this is another
situation that in general relativity you
can
solve exactly there's actually not that
many solutions in general relativity
that are exact there's a lot of
approximate solutions but
this is what is called a vacuole model
where you take a uniform
collection of dust but you take some
sphere and collapse all the particles to
the middle
so we know exactly what the metric of
space-time
is inside that hole right you have a
hole in space with all the matter in the
middle
rather than being uniformly spread and
we know
exactly how much expansion of the
universe there is
inside that hole and the answer is zero
there is no expansion of space
whatsoever inside that hole even though
the whole rest of the universe is
expanding okay
so as long as the expansion of the
universe is spherically symmetric around
us it's exactly analogous to a question
of
what if you have you know a a spherical
shell
of metal that you put an electric charge
on right so from outside
it looks like a ball that is
electrically charged and there's a
charge
but what's inside what is the electric
field inside the answer is zero
as long as it's spherically symmetric
there is literally zero field inside
likewise for the solar system as long as
the universe around us
is expanding spherically symmetrically
around us
there is literally no effect on what
goes on here in the solar system
okay here are three questions that i'm
grouping together and it's a little bit
complicated so bear with me they're long
questions
james says i haven't quite wrapped my
mind around the need for a past
hypothesis
to explain the arrow of time if i zoom
out and look at the model of the
universe as a whole it seems that simply
having a boundary condition
at the big bang along with the second
law is sufficient to result in a model
of the universe where entropy increases
when moving away from that boundary
condition and the entropy will be low by
definition at that boundary am i
thinking about this wrong
matt matt three mats in a row is the
person's name
uh i have a question about your thoughts
on time direction and land hours
principle landauer's principle by the
way parenthetically
is what uh attributes a growth of
entropy when you erase
some bit of information in a thermal
bath
so the question continues supposing that
the erasure of a memory increases the
entropy of the relevant
system what does this mean when we
choose to describe things in the
opposite direction of time
surely we say that towards the past
memories are erased
but that there is not an accompanying
increase in entropy should we say that
landauer's principle only applies to the
future
and finally nick shorten says i've heard
physicists talk about the time
reversibility of the laws of physics and
the linking of the arrow of time with
entropy
in many worlds where the schrodinger
equation is presumably time reversible
the splitting seems to only go one way
is this related to entropy
or an unrelated separate error of time
good so
all these three questions relate to the
idea that the second law of
thermodynamics that says that entropy
increases with time
is explained by this combination of two
things one thing
is the definition of entropy which says
that high entropy states
are associated with macroscopic
configurations that have many many
microscopic configurations associated
with them the entropy
is the number of the logarithm i should
say of the number of microscopic
configurations that look macroscopically
the same
that's thing number one and thing number
two is there's a boundary condition
so if you start the system in a low
entropy state in that case
there are just more ways to be high
entropy than low entropy so
if you let it go almost all or at least
the vast
majority of trajectories will increase
in entropy over time
so that second condition that there is a
boundary condition with low entropy is
called the past hypothesis and so
james is saying so james i'll confess i
don't quite exactly understand your
question what you've described is
exactly what people say
um that there is a boundary condition
at one end of time and that's the
boundary condition says that entropy is
low there
and we define that direction of time to
be the past and that's why we call it
the past hypothesis
so um that is exactly what we do
and you're saying you don't understand
why but you just described exactly what
is the correct thing to do so i think
you're thinking about it right
i'm not quite sure why you are why you
think you're disagreeing with the usual
way of
stating it there's no pre-existing
definition of past and future
there is the direction of lower entropy
and the direction of higher entropy and
we label
the direction of lower entropy to be the
past right
and to next question yes this is exactly
the same thing going on
with the schrodinger equation and
branching in many worlds
the fact that there were fewer branches
in the past
and the number of branches increases
toward the future is exactly because of
a low entropy
boundary condition in the past now
that's not to be too glib about it
there's still
issues to make that exactly rigorously
defined et cetera what do you mean by
low entropy etc
do you have a pre-existing division of
the world into environment
and system and stuff like that but
basically it's the same kind of thing
it's a cosmological boundary condition
that uh gives us the apparent asymmetry
time asymmetry
a branching from an underlying equation
which is perfectly symmetric
then the landauer's principle question
um i think that you're
cheating a little bit i need to actually
haven't thought about this one very
deeply so i might be
getting the wrong impression here i
think you're cheating when you say
surely we say that toward the past
memories are erased
um i think there's a difference between
being erased and not yet having been
created
right i mean it's true as we go into the
past there are fewer memories
because there's not as much past to
remember in some sense but if you
actually take
so like consider a memory um and the
memory for those of you who don't
listen to this kind of thing all the
time a memory in this case is just some
physical artifact some feature of the
present state of the world
to which we can attach a correlation
with some event
in the past okay so it's not just
necessarily memory in your brain
any record any photograph any document
that says something about the past
one of my favorite examples is a
footprint on the beach okay
if you come across a footprint on a
beach uh you
will be quite right in saying i bet
there used to be a foot
that landed there i bet that this is a
record of the passage of someone who
left a footprint
you might not be right there's a
possibility that the random motion of
the ocean
and the sand and so forth left a
footprint there
but given the evolution of entropy in
the universe and so forth
most such footprints are going to be
associated with a past event
namely um the walking down the beach of
some person with a foot that landed
there and left the footprint okay
so when if you were to erase that so if
you take a bucket of water and you pour
it over the footprint and you've now
erased it right
you've increased the entropy of the
universe you've shaken things up
it's an irreversible process if someone
comes across
the same patch of beach where the
footprint used to be
they don't know whether there was a
footprint there that you erased
or where there was never a footprint
there at all right so that's the that's
the definition of an irreversible
process you don't know how to go
backwards
whereas if you take the footprint and
evolve backward in time follow where it
came from right so unwind the clock and
see the person walking backwards and
their foot
exactly lands and where the footprint
was and they raised the foot and the
beach goes back to being perfectly flat
in some sense that's removing the memory
it's removing the footprint
but it's not erasing the memory in the
same way
that you erased it by pouring a bucket
of water over it right
and the reason why the two processes can
be so different
is because the reversed time one is
lowering entropy all the way
right is the universe is being traced
toward the direction
of lower entropy in the big bang so i
think
if i understand the question correctly i
think the answer is that your notion of
erasing a memory is not quite the same
in those two cases
roy rodenstein says in your february ask
me anything in 51 minutes
you cleanly dispel free will then in 56
minutes you offer advice to take
initiative
can you share how you think about this
sure
so i did not clearly dispel free will if
anything i
cleanly dispelled libertarian free will
right libertarian free will is exactly
the idea that we talked about earlier
that somehow
you are a law unto yourself you are not
beholden to the laws of physics
okay i don't believe in that very few
people do believe in that some do
actually probably the majority people in
the world very few you know philosophers
and neuroscientists and physicists
believe in that let's put it that way um
but
i'm a compatibleist so i think that it
is still useful to talk about free will
for example i give advice to people to
take initiative
um so what i would say is that the laws
of physics are the laws of physics
my willpower does not overcome them my
willpower is an emergent
creation of the laws of physics so
there's no libertarian free will
in that sense and yet when i describe
human beings when i talk about human
beings when i interact with human beings
including myself it is overwhelmingly
useful
to use that description of human beings
as decision-making agents
as people who can think about reasons
for doing things and on the basis of
those reasons
they can make decisions okay that's what
a compatibilist
is a compatibilist is someone who
recognizes that the laws of physics are
the laws of physics i cannot overcome
them
and yet there is a an absolutely clear
sense of volition and decision making
and free will that we have at the
emergent level of being human beings
and honestly in my less generous
moments i think that literally everyone
is a compatibilist but some of us are
willing to admit it and some of them
some of us are not i have never met a
free-will skeptic someone who doesn't
believe in free will
who also refuses to use the language of
people making choices
who always refuses to try to convince
people of things right i mean
if you don't have the ability to be
convinced because everything is
predetermined why would you ever
convince people of anything
why would you ever think that anything
is right or wrong you can't believe in
morality
if you don't believe in free will you
can't believe that i could make a right
decision
because you don't believe i'm making
decisions okay so i think that a lot of
people are compatible
they just don't like to use that
language that's my theory
like i said in my less generous moments
jim murphy says in the many worlds
theory we need to give branches of the
wave function different weights in order
to make sense of the observed
probabilities does this mean
somewhere out there there is a thickest
branch could there be any significance
to this idea of the trunk of the many
worlds tree
sure there should be a thickest branch
but i don't think that there's any
significance to it being i wouldn't call
it the trunk
right i mean a trunk is not just the
thickest part of the tree there's
something
kind of central about it in some very
real sense whereas
there's no center to the set of all
branches of the wave function of the
universe so
but yeah different branches will have
different weights if there's a finite
number of them one of them will be the
thickest there you go
will robinson says in the laws of
physics
in the laws underlying the physics of
everyday life are completely understood
you seem to focus on what we can observe
in the everyday world but
in some podcast statements you also
extend your conclusions to cover what we
could possibly build
tomorrow no star trek force fields etc
you seem very confident that a future
understanding of dark matter will not
lead to a similar technological change
in our everyday lives is this right and
if so what is that certainty rooted in
um it's not certainty it's never
certainty this is science
okay so we should never be certain but
we have different credences for
different
things we might believe in i did just
recently write a paper
about this where i tried to make the
case at a more technical level
than i have in blog posts and things
like that so you're welcome to look up
that paper
uh called the quantum field theory on
which everyday life supervenes or every
the everyday world supervenes
something like that and the point is
that
they're very good reasons to believe
that dark matter or higgs bosons or
anything like that you know grand
unification particles
are not going to lead to technological
changes
namely because uh we can't interact with
them
very much you know the higgs boson we
made we did interact with it right
we discovered it large hadron collider
and then it decays away in 10 to the
minus 21 seconds
it is completely impractical for any
technological
uh purpose that you might want to put it
to it goes away first first off you need
a 10 billion
particle accelerator to make one and
then it disappears in a zeptosecond
not very useful for technological
changes likewise dark matter
dark matter seems to be stable right
otherwise it wouldn't have survived for
the whole age of the universe
but you can't make it it interacts too
weakly with us if you had a dark matter
particle in front of you
you couldn't hold it in your hand it
would pass right through your hand
we know that's true because if it
wouldn't pass through your hand if it
would interact with you strongly enough
that not only could you hold in your
hand but you could trap it
using anything that we have at our
disposal
we would have done that a long time ago
people have been trying to do
exactly that and failing so dark matter
just goes right through you
and the similar reasoning goes for
anything else you might want to imagine
so there are plenty of possible new
particles
new forces etc but we will not have the
ability to manipulate them
in interesting technological ways um and
in fact
that that point is long past you know as
i mentioned in this paper
the last time we made a discovery in
fundamental physics not
uh higher level physics not you know
emergent level
uh materials or anything like that but
in fundamental physics you know particle
physics
quantum field theory gravity stuff like
that the last time we made a new
discovery
that actually had technological
implications was basically like the
1950s
okay we discovered pions and things like
that and those are like just
they're they're not stable but they're
stable enough that you can imagine
putting them to some use
since then for the past more than half
of a century
technological change has all been
putting the stuff that we know about the
fundamental ingredients we
already discovered long ago to work in
different ways and more complicated
configurations right and i think that's
what technological change is going to
continue to be and there's a lot of ways
to do that
so we have a lot of room for new
technological change but it will not be
based
in new fundamental physics discoveries
again
not a certainty i could be wrong it'd be
great if i were wrong
but that's the argument siraj rajan says
as a medical professional during my
european stint i had appreciated the
large population medical data sets we
had access to
due to the centralized medical data
collection systems that they have there
they also have a more interconnected
network network of labs
etc are there any interesting practices
or traditions you've noticed in
non-american physics or cosmology
universities that you wish you could
implement in the us
so i included this among the questions
to uh
say out loud because i think it's an
interesting question
sadly i have nothing interesting to add
to it i'm just offering it up to um
other listeners if they have anything
that they want to think about uh
spurred by this question you know and
partly
this is because i have not spent an
extremely large amount of time
in foreign universities i've visited
them for a few days or a couple weeks at
a time
even a couple weeks might be a slight
exaggeration i visited plenty of foreign
universities but not really hung out
and with enough time to get deeply
immersed in the culture of them
and also partly because my particular
kind of theoretical physics is you know
pencil and paper
there's not a lot of things you can do
in different ways you know theoretical
physics of this form i do it
is basically the same whether you're in
los angeles or paris or beijing
or seoul or wherever okay
so there's not a lot of differences if
anything
the the most noticeable thing is that
believe it or not
a lot of foreign universities have way
worse bureaucracy
than the united states does to get
reimbursed for travel expenses if you go
to a conference in france
is just such an enormous pain that it's
almost not worth it
sometimes they love their paperwork
there man like like no one's business
and so in in that sense i'm happier uh
for the american system but you know i'm
sure there are
uh different things but the things i
notice are like you know yeah they have
really good coffee and wine at the
conferences in paris so that that makes
up for the paperwork
anonymous says the game minecraft has
seed numbers used to generate their
worlds
if two players generate a massive world
with the same seed number they would
both start and walk hundreds of miles in
a direction
and get the same random block in front
of them without communicating
is this analogous to quantum
entanglement so no
it is not analogous to quantum
entanglement this is a crucial thing
this is why i think this is a good
question to answer
entanglement is not correlation okay i
mean it is correlation it's more than
that it's different than classical
correlation um it's the this is not
exactly your question but there's a
related famous example given by john
bell of bertelman's socks
right bertelman always used to wear two
different colored socks
he would never wear two socks that were
the same color so whenever you saw him
and if you saw that on one foot he was
wearing a green sock
you would instantly know without
actually seeing it the other sock was
not green
maybe it's purple or red or whatever but
you know it's not green and so bell
john bell is saying isn't that like
entanglement but he knows better he's
using an example he's saying
no entanglement is not like that it's
not just like that
and the reason why is because there is
some fact of the matter about the color
of
burtleman's left sock and right sock
there is some fact of the matter about
what your seed number is and therefore
what block will randomly quote unquote
randomly drop down in front of you
miles hundreds of miles away okay
there's a fact of the matter so there's
a correlation
you don't know that these two things are
in certain states but they
are in certain states okay the number
has been generated this hawk has been
put on the foot
whereas entanglement is a different kind
of thing because if i have two spins
and let's say they are oppositely
aligned so that an entangled state of
two spins
so that i know that if one is spin up
the other is spin down
or the other if the first has spin down
the other is spin up okay
so two things to note number one neither
one of them
has a definite state of its spin it's
not spin up or spin down it's in a
superposition of both that's different
than the classical analogy but if i
observe one
spin then the other one i will know okay
but more importantly
i could choose to measure along a
different direction remember we just
talked about how you can relate
spins in the z direction versus spins in
the x direction or y
direction etc so for this kind of
entangled state of two spins held by
alice and bob
i could choose to measure something
different i could choose to measure the
spin along the x-axis
rather than along the z-axis and it
would still be
true that the spins would be
anti-aligned so if i measure
my spin or alice measures her spin along
the x-axis
whatever answer she gets i now know that
bob very very far away
will get the opposite answer so it
wasn't a pre-existing correlation it
wasn't until i
chose to measure that that i could say
what
bob was going to see so it's not just
the existence of two copies of the same
thing
from a common cause even from an
accidental cause it's a kind of
relationship that is intrinsically
quantum mechanical
and you can't really analogize very well
classically
you see polvi says i was wondering does
it feel different now that you were in
uh that biden and harris are in charge
at least looking from afar it seems that
the first month has been full of
smaller and bigger changes in the right
direction uh yeah i think it absolutely
feels different i think that's actually
the good way
of putting it you know i mean the people
who are in charge of different
government organizations are now
experts in their fields rather than
close relatives and lawyers
of the president um decisions are being
made and i'm not going to agree with all
the decisions but they're being made by
people you know who are pretty competent
in their fields
and also you know the the this feeling
question
a lot of it comes down to what in both
physics
and in poker which is another you know
regime
arena that i always use to reach for for
my metaphors we would say has to do the
lowering of the temperature
okay you know in in
physics if you have a box of gas at very
low temperature everything the molecules
are not moving very much they're just
sitting there
if you raise the temperature heat it up
put your cup of coffee in the microwave
everything moves faster right
everything's jumping around and going
crazy
uh poker players use this as a metaphor
if
if you're at a table of poker players
and they're all very tight
right so they're all very reluctant to
bet like if someone does make a bet
everyone else folds
it's very kind of predictable that's a
low temperature situation
and if you just bring in a couple of new
players who
suddenly like always are raising and
betting and going crazy
in order to adapt to you know play well
against that different kind of style
you have to increase your frequency of
raising and betting
and stuff like that so the whole
temperature of the table goes up
and the switch from uh trump pence to
biden harris has lowered our political
temperature
that doesn't mean it's lowered the uh
polarization or the commitment of
republicans to oppose the democratic
agenda or anything like that but the
discourse
is just a fundamentally different kind
of style
that is going on you know we're we're
talking about
the actual um
technical problems of getting vaccine
doses
into the right hands as quickly as
possible we are not
talking about well you know the governor
of that state was mean to me therefore
i'm not going to give them any
uh aid or something like that you know
the state of texas
did not vote for joe biden nevertheless
no one ever even imagined that he would
fail to
give them aid when they recently had to
go through a lot of uh
troubles with um the temperature was
very low
the it was very very bad weather and the
electrical grid in texas
failed and a lot of people were in
trouble and uh yeah the federal
government helped out that's what the
federal government is supposed to do
it's not an issue now in the way that it
would have been a short while ago
thierry larue paquette says why are you
uncertain about hilbert
space's size so hilbert's base is the
saw is the
space of all possible wave functions of
a physical system so if you have a
spin that can either be spin up or spin
down that's a two-dimensional hilbert
space
but very quickly if you have something
like the position of a particle
just in good old non-relativistic
quantum mechanics well how many
different positions could you observe
if you measured the position of a
particle an infinite number
right any real number you could get as
an answer and therefore the hilbert
space the space of all wave functions
for a particle moving in one dimension
in non-relativistic quantum mechanics
is infinite dimensional the number of
dimensions of hilbert space is just the
number of possible
observational outcomes that are truly
distinct from one another
um that don't as they say that that
commute with each other a complete set
of commuting observables
uh so what about the real world right i
mean if a single particle has an
infinite dimensional hilbert space
surely the world which has lots of
particles
um has an infinite dimensional helper
space how could it be finite
well that idea of a single particle
described by
uh non-relevant quantum mechanics is not
the real world right it's it's a model
and it's a model that imagines that we
could divide space arbitrarily into
tiny regions which maybe we can't do in
the real world because the real world
has gravity uh so again i'll refer to a
paper that i wrote but i wrote a paper
with ningbao
and ashmit singh i think
saying that the hilbert space of quantum
gravity
is locally finite dimensional and the
reason why
is because something we mentioned way
earlier in the podcast talking about
black holes
when you try to put a lot of energy into
a quantum field in a world with gravity
you don't create whatever you want you
create a black hole there's too much
energy in a region
and we know that black holes have an
entropy stephen hawking told us that and
we know that entropy is finite
and there's a relationship i won't go
into details but there's a relationship
between the entropy
of a black hole and the dimensionality
of its hilbert space so it's a finite
number
so we think that in a world with gravity
in any region of space there's only a
finite
number of things that can happen there's
only a finite number of quantum
mechanical states that are truly
distinct from each other
that would lead us to believe that
hilbert's space is
locally finite dimensional and by the
word locally i mean
in a single region of space but then
how many regions of space are there
right we have our observable universe
which is a region of space
maybe it has a finite dimensional
hilbert space but maybe there's an
infinite number
of regions of space outside so that's
why we don't know we're
a little bit unsure about whether this
argument that quantum gravity
makes hilbert's space locally finite
dimensional is even true
i think it's right but we don't know for
sure because quantum gravity is tricky
and we don't know the total
dimensionality of hilbert space because
we don't know how many local regions of
space
there are that's okay lots of things we
don't know about the universe
andrei dinhu says as an advocate of many
worlds you probably agree with the
philosophical perspective labeled as
wave function realism
by david albert if so then what do you
make of the criticisms against
that position considering the waveform
function of the universe as the
fundamental ontological entity which
describes our world
um so i need to be a little bit
technical and nitpicky here i am not
a fan of wave function realism but you
have to understand what wave function
realism as david albert
uh posited it is supposed to mean so
david of course
one of the world's leading philosophers
of physics former mindscape guest
and what he says is the following and
i'm not even sure if he believes it i
mean this is something
which we do as as thinkers you know we
put forward ideas
as possibly true and then we investigate
them right we don't
just say well because i thought of it it
must be true so what david says is look
if i have um
let's say i have a particle in a box a
three-dimensional box
and in classical mechanics i would say
okay the particle lives in
the three-dimensional box and if i have
a quantum theory of that particle
then its wave function can be thought of
as a function of space as a function of
the three-dimensional space
in which the box lives because the wave
function assigns an
amplitude which i would square to get
the probability to every point
in that box every point in that
three-dimensional space so far so good
but david says look what if you have two
particles in the box okay then because
of entanglement there are not
two different wave functions for the two
particles there's one wave function for
the two particle
system and the two particle system even
though each individual particle
lives in a three-dimensional box the two
particle system lives in a
six-dimensional configuration space
three dimensions telling you where one
particle is three dimensions tell me
where the other particle is let's assume
they're not identical particles so an
electron and a proton for example
and so david says in that case the
quantum mechanical wave function is a
function
of the six-dimensional configuration
space
and if i have n particles in a
three-dimensional box
the wave function is a function of a
three n-dimensional
configuration space so he wants us to
imagine the idea that that kind of wave
function
not just a an abstract quantum state
but a function on configuration space 3n
dimensional configuration space
is what is real is the fundamental
ontology of the world
okay so in some sense the three
n-dimensional configuration space for
for this view
is more fundamental than the
three-dimensional
space that we call space okay so it's a
slightly cheeky point of view because we
all think that space is more fundamental
than configuration space in some sense
so i admire that cheekiness i think
that's a good thing to do but look i
don't
buy that ontology as it were
in a straightforward way uh and
for for a number of different reasons uh
the most basic is the world is not made
of particles
that's not the world sorry right i mean
the world is maybe made of quantum
fields but like i said gravity is not a
quantum field theory itself so
the world's made of something we don't
know what it is but it's definitely not
a bunch of non-relativistic particles
so that straightforward literal
wave function of n particles ontology
certainly is a non-starter in my view
as describing fundamental reality but
also that wave function is in my mind
you know a representation of a quantum
state
it's a way of describing and giving the
information contained in a quantum state
but it's a highly non-unique way of
giving that information
for example i'm not sure andre how much
into quantum mechanics you are
but there is the position basis there's
also the momentum basis
right so i can equally well describe
that n particle state in the momentum
basis
in which case the wave function is a
function of momentum space not of
configuration space
so i certainly can't imagine taking
configuration space as fundamental as
the fundamental arena in which wave
functions live
what i can do is be is be even more
abstract than david was proposing to be
and say what really exists is just a
vector in hilbert space
and you can represent such vectors in
hilbert space as
functions of configuration space you can
represent them just as well as functions
of
momentum space or literally an infinite
number of other choices it's it's just
like when we were talking in the
very first special relativity talk when
i said
choosing coordinate systems is not an
objective physical thing
it's a choice made by human beings
likewise choosing representations of
quantum states
is not an objective physical thing so
the thing that is real
in my mind is the vector in hilbert
space okay
now most philosophers of physics would
say that's crazy talk
and they would say it because there's
not enough structure in hilbert's space
to recover the reality of the world and
david wallace who's another leading
philosopher of physics has said this out
loud i believe the phrase he used was it
would be naive in the extreme to believe
that and i i know that
off the top of my head because i'm
writing a paper right now supposed to
finish it this week
and yet here i am doing amas but i love
doing the ama so it's okay anyway i'm
writing a paper
that gives um a defense an apologia for
this view that really is just the wave
function
uh as a vector in hilbert space that
should be considered real not
configuration space or momentum space so
i'm quoting david wallace as saying
that my view is not even the extreme but
i think that's just because people don't
appreciate there is
just enough structure in hilbert's face
to do everything you want and that's
what you want
you want to be able to reconstruct the
complicated world around us from the
minimal amount of structure
i think that's what we can do okay
nathaniel zabel says
i've always sort of romanticized
academia and studying physics i gave it
a go and realized that it may not be for
me
and now i'm most of the way through an
electrical engineering undergrad degree
so my question is how if at all do you
see engineers involved in real physics
well they're all over the place you know
i mean it depends on what you mean by
real physics but
most of physics not what i do but most
of physics
involves experiments in a very intimate
way right
building apparatuses uh designing
detectors that are the world's most
precise and robust there's an enormous
amount of engineering that goes into
this you know you don't think that
large hadron collider was built by
physicists do you
i mean there's a lot of physicists
involved but there's a lot of engineers
technical people uh you know contractors
etc
someone had to pour concrete etc so yeah
if you're interested
in um being involved in the broader
project of physics from an electrical
engineering
degree point of view that's 100 percent
possible i'm not the world's expert
about
how to do it but it's absolutely
possible
carlos nunez says if you could have a
superpower what would it be
and why um yeah i think
let me see i think the answer is obvious
which is teleportation
and you know look there's slight
ill-definededness in the question
because what counts as a superpower like
is omniscience uh superpower well i get
to do that
um you know another obvious choice would
be uh
flying or you know telepathy is a good
one reading other people's minds
certainly reading other people's minds
would would give you great
advantages going through life i also
think it'd be really depressing right i
think that minds are messy places that
people don't have complete control over
and i don't necessarily want to know
what other people are thinking about
everything
so telepathy might be more than i want
access to flying seems cool
but if you believe that you have some uh
limitation on your speed
then teleportation is way cooler so i'm
interpreting the question as
you know going through the lists of
super powers that superheroes tend to
have so i'm excluding omniscience or
something like that
uh teleportation would be great do you
think i can walk out the door
and suddenly have lunch in paris or you
know breakfast in tokyo
uh that would be pretty awesome don't
have to fly don't wait in line with tsa
yeah that would be a good superpower in
my view
stephen klein says the sun is hot the
93 or so million miles of space between
earth and the sun is cold
near absolute zero how is it that the
heat of the sun
can travel that distance through cold
without heating space up and then get
hot again when it hits earth
well the reason why i include this
question is because it's a good one
exactly because we are usually sloppy
about using words like hot and cold okay
if you're really really strict and you
shouldn't be but if you are really
really strict you should only
attribute a temperature to a system that
is
at or near thermal equilibrium okay that
a system that has been given a chance
to equilibrate and come to a constant
temperature everywhere then we have a
well-defined notion of what it means
to be at a temperature if you are near
the surface of the sun
well then you're pretty close okay then
everywhere around you is the same
temperature
everywhere around you is the same
density of matter etc you're pretty
if you're not outside but right inside
the sun that's a pretty good
approximation
but if you're in the space in between
the earth and the sun
you're nowhere near thermal equilibrium
exactly because in most directions you
look
it's really cold the sky is dark but in
one direction you look toward the sun
it's really hot and bright
okay that is a paradigmatic example of
not being in thermal equilibrium
so it's not that space is cold
in between the earth and the sun it's
that space doesn't have a temperature
strictly speaking it's not a system that
is in thermal equilibrium
there's the other part of the answer
which is that space is not a thing you
can't heat up space
space is the thing through which other
things travel at this level of
description so um you should another
reason why you should not attribute a
temperature to it but
if that's a deflationary answer then
sorry but that's the right way i think
to think about these things
costello rotary says why isn't there an
italian translation of the big picture
will it happen and can i do it myself
so i answer this question because maybe
it uh helps
i get this kind of question usually by
email a bunch of times you know can i
translate your book
um as far as i remember there is no
italian translation of the big picture
and no
no current plans for one i believe that
they are currently in the process
of translating something deeply hidden
but the big picture i don't think i have
an italian contract for so the point is
you know look the publishing business is
a business
okay uh they people get paid people earn
their living doing it
you need to have contracts and dollar
amounts or lira amounts or euro amounts
or whatever
um so a lot of people
from different countries write in and
say there is no translation in my
language of your book can i
translate it and the answer is no you
can't
what you can do i'm not sure if this
ever works but in principle
you could interest a publishing
house in um
getting a translation done and maybe you
can even volunteer your service or
let yourself be hired for money as the
translator okay
but the actual translation and
publishing of a foreign language edition
of a book
has to be done through a publishing
house with a contract etc
so if you have a favorite italian
publisher
especially one that you know does
translations of
english language science books then by
all means pester them
to uh offering a contract to my agent to
uh
do a translation usually you know for
those of you who are out there
[Music]
interested in writing books and things
like that in the economics of the
business
foreign language editions of books are
not a good way to get rich
like if you write a book in english most
of the people buying your book will buy
the english version not a foreign
language version
so uh you know you can make a few
hundred a few thousand dollars here and
there depending on the version but
um i'm not saying all this because i
want to get rich off the italian edition
of the big picture that is not going to
happen but
there are legal things to keep in mind
and there are italian there are italians
who work for publishing houses who need
to earn a living so
that's the way to get it done ben turner
says you mentioned before you had
previously considered going to law
school
if you'd been a lawyer another life what
kind of lawyer would you have been
you know honestly i would have been a
law professor
i don't like i i don't know because i
haven't tried it but
the romance here is not me being in
court
and being perry mason or whatever uh
it's thinking about
the idea of the attraction of law school
was that law is sort of an intersection
of logical thinking and reasoning with
down-to-earth human concerns right um
it's not
the world you know finding out the truth
about the world outside but there is
legal theory
constitutional theory things like that
and that's what attracts me so i think
that doing
that as a law professor would have been
a better fit to me than to be like a
corporate lawyer
or a even a constitutional lawyer or
something like that
chris fautosh says you talk about
anti-dissider space often but where do
we find that in our universe isn't
space-time a decenter space
so d sitter space was
is a solution to einstein's equations
for general relativity
that you can get if you start with an
empty
universe that has a non-zero vacuum
energy that has a non-zero cosmological
constant a positive
value of cosmological constant so de
sitter villum de sitter way back in the
days i don't know 1917 or something like
that
um very soon after general relativity
came along
solved the equations for general
relativity with a positive cosmological
constant we call it the sitter space
we don't live into sitter space our
space time is not to sitter space
because there is stuff in our universe
other than the vacuum right there are
stars and planets and dark matter
the better thing to say is that as time
goes on
that stuff is emptying out and we are
approaching we're asymptoting toward the
sitter space and maybe in the future
we're going to look more and more like
sitter space
um antidesigner space is an analogous
thing but what would happen if you get a
negative
cosmological constant so there's no no
worries about a negative number for the
vacuum energy it's just as physically
allowed so you can imagine cosmologies
with the negative vacuum energy
solve the equations we call it
anti-desire space there's no mr
anti-dissider but i don't know who did
anti-dissider space first
um the reason why anti-dissider space is
so often mentioned is because it is a
wonderful
toy model for quantum gravity and it's
wonderful because of the discovery in
the mid 1990s
from mon maldasena that quantum gravity
with anti-dissider boundary conditions
is related to
and maybe is exactly the same as
a quantum field theory without gravity
living on the boundary that's the ads
cft correspondence ads being
anti-dissider
cft meaning conformal field theory a
particular kind of quantum field theory
so the idea so you might say well okay
that's good
if you have this correspondence between
a theory of gravity and a three without
gravity
then we can use our knowledge of
non-gravitational
quantum field theory to learn something
about gravity yes that is the
motivation behind ads cft correspondence
being so popular in the physics
literature
um but you might say but but who cares
if it's not our world right
and the answer would be well we know so
little about quantum gravity like
we think that information is preserved
when black holes evaporate but we don't
know how
maybe studying a problem like that in
the context of the adscft correspondence
teaches us something
fundamental about quantum gravity that
will continue to be true
or maybe less so but uh equally good
will inspire some true thing in the real
world
in the decenter space world i think this
is a reason why
i mean let's let's put it this way this
is the generous way
of spinning why so many people care
about ads cft
because they're trying to learn robust
features of quantum gravity in a
well-controlled
example that hopefully we can then
port over to more realistic situations
there is a less generous construction uh
which would say
it's just full employment like once you
have ads cfd there's a million questions
you can ask and answer
a million equations you can write down
and solve them and whether or not
it's related to the real world that's
what physicists like to do so they do it
okay
the truth is probably somewhere in
between those two things
there is definitely some uh you know
treadmill kind of work
you're on the hamster wheel of solving
equations in the ads cft correspondence
and you lose sight to the bigger picture
but there's absolutely also work that
has come out of
ads cft that potentially has interesting
ramifications for the real world so
somewhere in between probably is the
truth humberto nani says is it possible
that the universe
looks flat because it has not had enough
time or space to express its curvature
or
that is that possibility ruled out by
observations um
no it's absolutely possible so you know
we sometimes
say that when we talk about the
curvature of
space in cosmology there are three
choices
there's positively curved negatively
curved and zero flat
right well you know that's not a false
statement but it's also not
uh the most information conveying
statement
a better way to say it is that there is
for every possible geometry of space and
these are
not arbitrary geometries but homogeneous
and isotropic geometries there's only
those three choices
you can attach a real number to any such
geometry called the radius of curvature
okay the radius of curvature of a sphere
is literally the radius
right how big is the sphere spheres are
positively curved
so if you take a sphere and make it
bigger and bigger right bigger and
bigger radius of curvature
um in the limit where it becomes an
infinitely big radius of curvature
it's flat you you get the plane this is
a you can check this mathematically
and then you can sort of come back the
other side you can say well what if i
have a
negative radius of curvature that's what
you would attach to a hyperbolic
geometry a negatively curved uh surface
so
even though there are three classes of
geometries
of universe positively curved negatively
curved or flat there's really
a continuum of actual geometries from
infinite negatively infinite curvature
to positively infinite curvature so what
we're measuring when we measure the
curvature of the universe is a real
number
not a discrete choice of three different
possibilities so the measurement that we
do
of the curvature of the universe has
error bars
and right now the curvature of the
universe as we've measured it is
compatible with zero curvature
compatible with being flat uh but it's
also compatible with a very large radius
of curvature that is either positive or
negative
so as those error bars get better or as
our observations get stronger we might
discover
that the universe is a little bit
negatively curved or positively curved
that is absolutely
possible christopher matthews says as
someone who hasn't solved an equation
since high school
i don't have a great sense for what is
actually involved when you talk about
solving sort of equations a working
physicist would solve
is that something you could describe or
would i need a stronger background to
grasp it
um it's hard to describe just because
there's so many different equations
right i mean there's a lot of different
techniques for solving equations that
physicists use
um sometimes pretty simple like you know
often times uh you know i already
mentioned earlier that if you have a
bunch of particles in a box you can
describe them in position space
or in momentum space well there's a
technique there's a mathematical
technique for
transforming from one to the other
called fourier transforms
and so many systems that are very
complicated in position space are easy
to solve in momentum space you do that
kind of integral
transform other times you have a simple
differential equation like the
friedman equation for the expansion of
the universe and even though it's very
simple
if you have some complicated stuff in
the universe you're just going to solve
it numerically you're just going to put
it on a computer
and solve it in yet other cases you have
something like
feynman diagrams for a scattering
process and fineman has given you a
little recipe for attaching to each
diagram an integral or a set of
integrals to do
and a set of tricks like literally
there's something that you can look up
in quantum field theory books called
feynman's trick for doing integrals
and it's a trick that is specific for
the kind of integrals that appear
in vitamin diagram calculations
other areas of physics will have
matrices that you need to
diagonalize or find the eigenvalues of
you know there's just a whole bunch of
different techniques
so i'm not giving you a very helpful
answer but
uh it's a big heterogeneous mess that's
that's all i can really
say for it sorry okay here's a group of
questions i'm going to group together
robert casan says did your conversation
with russ schaefer landau change your
degree of belief
in moral constructivism um
stephen berniger says did your podcast
with robert sapolsky yield any new
insights about how we humans should deal
with moral challenges
and andre says in your recent podcast
with robert sapolsky you didn't push
back on his views against free will what
is your response to his arguments
against compatibilism so
the grouping is that my mind changed uh
when i did these podcasts
and nope my minds didn't really change
like my amount of information increased
i learned something about it
um but for the rush shaffer landau uh
podcast for example
you know he is really quite explicitly
you know he's very honest and enamorable
about it he's a
he's basing his moral realism on our
intuitions
we have an intuition about what is right
and what is wrong and he thinks that
deserves you know being taken seriously
as a moral realist and i just don't i'm
like wow our intuitions
which clearly were shaped by evolution
and all sorts of weird things in the
structure of our brains and so forth
i can't imagine attaching moral
uh heft to what those intuitions are so
no i
understand better where he's coming from
but my mind did not change um
with robert sapolsky yes you know he
take you know he knows much better than
i do what are the different
actual characteristics of the world that
go into making us make certain choices
and do certain behaviors um
and he concludes from that that there's
no free will because he can see why
we're making all these different choices
uh from a philosophical point of view i
don't think this has much to do
with compatibilism the philosophical
case
is about what i said before uh is the
best language that we have for talking
about human beings and describing their
behaviors one in which they are agents
making choices
and even if i know that there is
something called
um the amygdala and there are hormones
and there are genetic behaviors
and there are things that happen in your
childhood or in the womb
and etc all of these i can know all of
these things
but as long as a person is not
sufficiently brain damaged or something
like that
that my best way of thinking about them
is as a person i could give reasons to
and they could respond to those reasons
and make choices based on those reasons
then as that's what i mean by free will
so i don't think that zapolsky has
um uh really thought about the
philosophical argument one way or the
other
which is fine that's not his job that's
not what he is doing
so it does not change my personal view
on free will
and again as i said before in the
podcast i'm not there to ride my hobby
horses you know i
if i have robert sapolsky on the podcast
i want to hear his insight about how the
brain works i don't want to
have a long complicated semantic
argument over how we should think about
free will
okay um and how the question about how
whether or not that podcast changed how
we humans should deal with moral
challenges again you know
no not really and i think this is
why i don't like the free will
discussion that we have in the modern
world
because there are really important
questions
about practical things we should do
punishing people who behave badly
treating people who have mental
disorders or addictions or things like
that
these are real questions okay that i
don't have any simple answers to
to me these questions are largely
orthogonal
to the free will questions you know
these are all questions about which i am
very much a consequentialist
what is the thing we can do to make
things better
to the extent that we agree on what
should be better you know if someone is
addicted to heroin it would be better if
they were not uh if someone murdered
someone it'd be better if they didn't
murder people okay
so we agree on what the goals are and we
have a very instrumentalist question how
do we
get those goals and that seems to have
nothing to do with how we think about
free will
in my mind it has a lot to do with the
biology sure
so that's the the discussion i think
should be going on
not should we think about free will or
not but
given what we know about biology and
psychology and pharmacology and
and uh the legal system and all these
things how
should we make all those systems the
best to get the outcomes we want and if
no one ever used words like free will in
that discussion i think the discussion
will be way better
uh than it is okay gary miller says
why are you skeptical of avi loeb's view
that uma
sorry um
man i was really good at pronouncing
that when i talked to avi but i've lost
the ability
why are you skeptical that it's
artificially made as a layperson i think
it's a fascinating idea but rely
entirely on what the experts think
what do you think on amumua being
artificial versus natural
well partially it's a question of priors
right
you know i think that most objects
flying through the solar system
are much more likely to be natural than
artificial so i would need really good
evidence
to change my mind before i sort of
switched over you know it just
for the simple reason that you know i
presume
in my way of thinking about life in the
galaxy
that most of the stuff in the galaxy is
natural not artificial um and
you know the the specific scenario being
put forward
is a little bit weird right i mean
on the one hand it's supposed to be a
solar sail
you're supposed to say well it's more
likely
that it would pass close by the sun
because it's
meant to be a solar sail and use the sun
but why exactly like is it
you know where is it aiming why didn't
they just aim it where they're supposed
to aim it rather than like send it on
trajectory past the sun
why is the solar sail the right thing to
be why didn't it
uh give off some signal that makes it
perfectly clear that it's
that it's artificial and so forth like
the bigger context here
is not very convincing to me um on the
other hand
i'm very much in agreement that we
should take it seriously that's why i
had obvi on the podcast you know again
i don't i i invite people on the podcast
who i disagree with but not people who i
don't think are worth listening to
so it's very much worth taking that
seriously
and you know i do think that avi um
like more than sapolsky or schaefer
landau
albi did shift my credences a little bit
toward taking the possibility of
detecting
extraterrestrial life a little bit more
seriously than i usually do
uh he didn't change my uh credences on
whether artificial life exists
but there is some you know payoff to
finding it if it's out there
uh especially defining it before they
find us so
i think that's a good uh lesson to learn
joseph tangretti says if two massive
objects exist in space-time and and are
x distance apart
how does space-time know the distance
and impute the proper amount of gravity
between the two
objects well the answer is because space
time is not empty
space time contains fields at every
point in particular in this case
it contains the metric tensor field
which we previously referenced
the metric tensor is just a fancy way of
saying space time has a geometry
uh the metric tensor is what keeps track
of what that geometry is
and so uh there is something that
stretches in between
these two objects and that thing that
metric obeys an equation
einstein's equation of general
relativity that's how it knows that's
why there's not
any question of spooky action at a
distance in general relativity
of course isaac newton did worry about
exactly this because he didn't know
about the metric tensor he didn't know
about fields
more generally so he didn't know how
objects did this but we've learned a lot
since newton's time okay aman
nilapa says i'm a naturalist such as
yourself however
having been brought up in india i've
always been cognizant of multiple claims
that there is a deep
non-naturalistic perhaps metaphysical
truth
on offer to someone who is prepared to
dedicate themselves to a rigorous and
long-term mental and physical discipline
the catch is that one has to dedicate
one's life to such a pursuit
and another catch seems to be that the
said truth is claimed to be
only expressible by a metaphors and
eludes a direct and precise description
however from all accounts the nature of
the truth that one discovers
is not just deeply gratifying and
beautiful but also largely consistent
as can be evidenced from the similarity
in the writings of those who are
believed to have done a particularly
good job of walking
these disciplines what in your opinion
should be one's attitude towards claims
such
as these so this is a really good
question you know i don't i hope that no
one listening is dismissing
this question you know so the claim is
that there are
truths of some sort which are left
vague the sort of truth that you're
getting here is left vague
that can only be reached with a certain
kind of investment right
and that once you do reach that truth
you can't even convey it to those
who have not made that investment so is
this
worth taking seriously right like if
it's if it's all just hokum
then you would waste a lot of time if
you put in that investment
um so i don't you know i'm so i'm a
little skeptical
honestly but i'm willing to be
open-minded about something like this
you know so let's
let's think about the in-principle
question before we think about specific
examples
in principle uh is it possible there are
kinds of truths realizations
um revelations if you want to call them
that
they can only be reached by meditation
or practice or something like that and
then even when you
attain them you can't share them with
anyone so i think that's possible
like i can imagine something like that
is correct
i don't think that the kinds of truths
being obtained that way would be
physics truths or math truths i think
those kinds of truths are
essentially always expressible in
non-metaphorical ways
but you might be able to reach truths
about yourself you know about uh how you
should think about yourself as a person
in the world how you should live your
life what you should value those kinds
of things
um i certainly would be much more
um so what i just said is i think it's
possible in principle yes it's
conceivable
on the other hand i still am skeptical
in part because i think it'll be much
more convincing if you could
give some flavor of those truths even to
those of us who've not gone through the
discipline right
um you know being a scientist doing
science one of the lessons you learn
is uh as i think it was feynman who said
you know um you have to be careful not
to fool yourself because you're the
easiest person to fool
and this kind of thing where oh i have
some special knowledge but i can't tell
you what it is
man that just seems ripe for fooling
yourself right like
you have a vested interest because you
put in a lot of work
uh put a lot of your own time in
uh attaining this kind of truth and so
you're
certainly predisposed to think that it's
there and then you're predisposed to
think that you've done it right uh so
it's hard to be skeptical it's hard to
stop yourself from fooling yourself
and finally if it were true that this
these kinds of truths were obtained then
i would expect
there to be even if the people who
gained that truth were not able to
convey it non-metaphorically
i would expect there to be some kind of
tangible
difference in that person a wisdom or
knowledge or something like that and i
don't see it
i think that you know people who uh
spend a lot of time meditating
or you know monks or priests or mystics
or so forth
in my experience which is admittedly
limited
in these regimes but they're the same
kind of people that i see otherwise
they're not any better
doing physics i know that they might be
more peaceful but i don't you know i
don't always see that
even to be very honest um i went to a
catholic school it's not quite the same
but you know
there's something uh similar there
um so yeah you know so i i would tend to
be skeptical
but i i don't in any sense claim to know
for sure
or to even be unpersuadable about those
things
greg says what are your thoughts about
the risk of setting off an a.i
apocalypse i.e the possibility of
creating hyper-intelligent
self-replicating and self-improving
beings
that would ultimately result in a net
detriment to humanity
um so i have conflicting thoughts about
this you're asking me
my thoughts on one side i absolutely
think there is a worry here worth
worrying about
right and putting aside the buzzword
language of ai and hyperintelligence
we're creating systems we don't
understand we're creating
complex systems artificially constructed
that it is hard for us
to be specific about what they do what
how they will respond
under different circumstances and that's
just dangerous
right we're you know um
technological progress has brought us to
the point where human beings can create
enormously powerful things it would make
me happier if we
really really really understood those
things we're creating and we don't
always okay that's one side of it the
other side
the much more skeptical side is i think
that people
who i've heard talk about this to my
mind
are just being way naive about
how they anthropomorphize uh
ai systems you know they use words like
hyper-intelligent
um they use words like values and morals
that they attribute
to these systems and there might be a
sense in which these words have some
relation to what's going on
but and this is not i'm not trying to
say that artificially constructed
systems
can't be intelligent or even conscious
or whatever
i'm just saying that to the extent
that we create systems that have
something like intelligence or
consciousness or whatever or values or
morals
i suspect that those systems will be
wildly different
than human intelligence and values and
morals
and i think that i'm just very
unconvinced by the
discussions i've heard about you know
how to make them value the same thing we
value like how in the world do you think
that we
can tell them what to value like if
they're really hyper-intelligent to the
point where
they're like us they're going to decide
what to value
they're not going to listen to us we
can't bake it in if we bake in
instructions
then they're not really as intelligent
and and self-aware and self-controlling
to the extent that we want them to be
so i think that the real problem is not
this simple-minded thing that they're so
smarter so much smarter than we are that
we become sort of lesser beings
the real problem is that these systems
are going to be so
different than what we think of as an
intelligent agent
that they'll be totally unpredictable
and that's a worry i agree that that's a
worry i hope that we are worrying about
it to the right extent
kaiten says in your book from eternity
here you wrote to this day scientists
haven't determined
yet to anyone's satisfaction whether the
universe will continue to evolve forever
or whether it will eventually settle
into a placid state of equilibrium
but given an infinite period of time for
something to happen why wouldn't
any equilibrium eventually break perhaps
as a result of quantum fluctuations
so um yeah there's com
the short answer is because there are
competing infinities here
if you have a system which is sort of a
finite
state system there's only finite number
of things that can happen
or even a bounded state system so
there's there's sort of a real number of
things that can happen
but they happen in a circle or in some
bounded region
of space or configuration space
and that thing lasts for an infinitely
long time
and the dynamics are sort of
irreversible
okay i'm sorry the dynamics are
reversible so
let me back up i'm making too many
assumptions here to even make the
conclusion clear
think of all the different possible
dynamics of a particle moving on a disk
okay so you have a disk so you have
literally some little
circular thing and its interior and you
say
i have a particle so a point a little
mathematical idealized point moving on
the disk
and the there are different kinds of
dynamics
i can imagine one would be a kind of
random dynamics where the particle
wanders around in a random walk and it
will come back to where it started etc
but there are other kinds of dynamics
where the particles goes in a circle
forever or a figure eight forever or
whatever
and there's a third kind of dynamics
where it can just sort of spiral
into the middle and just stay in the
middle forever
so in all of these cases the particle
evolves for an empty long time
but in some cases it just fills the
space of possibilities over and over
again
and in other cases it just goes to a
single point and stops
so in this space of all possible
dynamics you can have anything you want
in that set of circumstances if you put
on the extra
restriction that the dynamics are like
the reversible dynamics of
the real world of the schrodinger
equation or whatever then the system
will not
simply wind down to a point because that
that's not reversible once you're at the
point you can you don't know where you
came from
um however maybe
the world the universe doesn't have a
bounded space of possibilities right
if you have both infinite time but also
an infinite space of possibilities then
any given region of the universe can
wander into an equilibrium and never
leave
that is absolutely mathematically
possible so there's no
to to get to your question there's no
guarantee that just because there's an
infinite amount of time
you will return to any particular place
like if you are walking on the real
numbers and you're walking in the
increasing direction and you go you know
one two three four
five you can keep going forever you're
never gonna get back to one
if you just keep walking in the same
direction and the universe might be like
that
gordon bamber says my assumption is that
dark matter interacts only
gravitationally with normal matter there
must be occasions when a black hole
equates a large amount of dark matter
if dark matter does not emit
electromagnetic radiation then could the
resulting energetic accretion disk be
detected at all
so so your the assumptions are not quite
mutually compatible gordon
um it's fine to assume the dark matter
interacts only gravitationally with
normal matter that's a that's
a possibility uh the question is does
the dark matter interact only
gravitationally with itself and
maybe it even only gravitationally is an
exaggeration maybe just doesn't
interact very strongly with itself or
with ordinary matter okay
in that case so if dark matter mostly
interacts gravitationally
sure dark matter can be absorbed by
black holes
but not a lot of it because the reason
why ordinary matter gets absorbed by
black holes is because ordinary matter
undergoes dissipation
when atoms of ordinary matter bump into
each other
they can emit photons and lose energy
that's why you make an accretion disk
because and the recreation disk is
shining because there's a dissipation
filled system where the the matter bumps
into other matter
loses energy increases the entropy of
the universe and settles into a disk
okay none of that happens for dark
matter
dark matter typically would just zoom
right by the black hole it would have to
hit it
right on to be absorbed by it whereas
ordinary matter
it can come near the black hole and if
it were all by itself in the universe it
would go right by
but it's not it bumps into some other
ordinary matter loses energy and spirals
into the black hole
so mostly black holes are going to be
eating up ordinary matter
not dark matter so there is no accretion
disk of dark matter even if there is
dark matter being absorbed by the black
hole
and if there were we couldn't detect it
because it would be subdominant to the
ordinary matter
in a typical situation okay
jim burnside says if dark energy
is causing the galaxies to travel apart
at an accelerating rate
at very high velocities then i don't
understand how the milky way can be on a
collision course with andromeda
um well i should have put this up with
the previous questions about dark energy
in the solar system
dark energy is not pushing the milky way
away from andromeda
um that that idea that the universe is
overall expanding
is only true on the larger scales it's
an approximation that gets better and
better
as you consider galaxies that are
further and further away
the milky way and andromeda are near to
each other they are gravitationally
bound to each other
it's just like the earth and the sun are
gravitationally bound to each other
so the milky way and andromeda have
broken away from the larger expansion of
the universe and dark energy does not
change that fact
last question is from acac acac
i was re-listening to your mindscape
episode with leonard suskind
in the end he talks about his father and
wanting to teach science to him and
others above
a scientific american level was this an
inspiration for your biggest ideas in
the universe
series and the textbook you are or were
working on
um not quite in exactly that
way you know um i had less lofty
inspirations or at least different
inspirations
you know the big picture question here
as it were
is that i've always had an interest in
explaining and talking about and
discussing physics with a broad audience
not just my fellow physicists i think
it's part of the fun honestly
in doing it you know i've said it many
times before
the kind of physics that i do doesn't
cure cancer
or lead to technological investigations
uh improvements
all it does is help us understand the
universe better so to understand the
universe better and then to not tell
anyone
that you've understood it better it
seems crazy to me so i really like
that part of the enterprise
including making videos and so forth the
biggest ideas videos in particular
honestly i think i said this
somewhere but maybe didn't get enough
credit but my friend lauren gunderson
who is a playwright
she's actually the most published or
most produced playwright in the united
states
working today and uh when the pandemic
hit
and when we started to be locked down
she started doing
uh playwriting lessons online you know
as
a way to keep people connected and uh
talking to each other and doing things
and learning
improving themselves and so that fact
that she did that was the immediate
inspiration
for me for doing the biggest ideas in
the universe series i'm like well that's
something i can do i can make little
videos teaching people about physics
and you know the q and a videos were uh
part of that inspiration that it was not
going to be just me talking
it would be some interaction of some
form
right and now the question that i
honestly even though was only
last year i don't even remember how
i chose exactly the level right so
the thing that makes those videos
interesting in my mind
is that they're higher level and in a
form of in the sense of being technical
and mathematical
than most popular physics discussions
while being lower level than most
textbook-y
discussions right um so and that's a
niche that is
that is unfilled uh to a very large
extent
and so i'm very happy that the videos
ended up
being in that niche and i would like to
turn them into a book someday
that is also in that niche because i
think that is is not filled as much as
it could be
but i really don't remember how
conscious that choice was or was just
like i started talking and that's where
they went
i would have to think back and you know
um
it all moved very quickly because
honestly i had to rush out and get the
equipment
to uh start the videos before everything
locked down
and then once i started them i put
myself on this weekly
uh schedule that i didn't have a lot of
time to sit back and reflect so
they happened you know they were i
didn't do a lot of research for them it
was just mostly stuff that i thought
that i knew already
that i could share with a broad audience
uh and as everyone knows who saw them my
uh video quality fluctuated with time
mostly improved but fluctuated a little
bit and uh
and it was great fun but it wasn't
something that i put a lot of
pre-planning
into um i'm not a really great
pre-planner kind of guy like once i'd
gone out and purchased the green screen
and everything
i wanted to start making videos i didn't
want to what i should have done was like
watch 20 hours of other youtube videos
about how to make good videos right
that's what i should have done
i didn't do that i just uh plunged into
it and
the result is up there and we'll be
there on youtube
forever or at least as long as there is
youtube forever is an exaggeration but
i hope people enjoyed it i hope people
enjoy the podcast i hope people enjoy
the ama
i hope you uh like how it went i still
did probably many
probably a little bit too many questions
i went too long
in this ama but um i think it works
picking some questions that i want to
answer because i'm more enthusiastic
about the answering
i think maybe that happened maybe i'll
try to be even a little bit more
persnickety about which questions to
answer next time
so that i can i can just take the
questions that are inspiring me to give
interesting answers
and focus on those but i do solicit
feedback let me know
how you think it went thanks for
listening bye
[Music]
you